That is
in last place is only five games behind the team that is in
first place.
I'm muted by the way.
Instead of three points for win.
Sorry, I was playing a game.
No!
That's me.
That is Miles's team, which is if you, for instance, if
Miles' team played Brawl Pro's team, who's in first place
right now, and five owed them, then they would go from last
for first and Brawl Pro's team would no longer be in first
place.
So there's a huge amount of points on the line today to
incentivize, you know, playing the first day, then learning
and coming back on Friday, playing again and then doing the
cheating for Sunday.
So you'll be playing everybody again today.
All of you did this on Wednesday.
So you're all experienced and you know how to do it now.
We've all done this together before.
And then this is your chance to beat up the people who got
you on Wednesday and show off the stuff that you've learned
and work with your coaches and get some new stuff, some new
data.
And it's all worth more points.
So it's going to be really important.
Every game is really, really important.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
I took a screenshot.
It's a ton of points.
So good luck out there.
No pressure.
Right.
I was about to say.
Yeah, no pressure.
Sorry, we're listening on Intel.
Almost double.
It's like double Jeopardy basically.
Everything is worth almost double.
So if you did great on Wednesday, I learned the low kick
chat.
On Wednesday, it's time to show all the stuff that you
learned.
That is my fifth move.
do this boom boom boom boom and then i do this this is my
fifth move the fifth move and i think for a lot of people
tomorrow if you're in the la area and i do and then i do
this and then i do this that is my fifth move i'm not
listening by the way they're talking about setup stuff i'm
grinding oh damn yeah i'm on my way to drive over there pull
up make the trim but yeah uh otherwise any questions
anything anybody needs to know or we down the game if i lose
any matches i blame brawl pro's absence okay yeah i'm with
you that's fair yeah that's awesome we're not trying to what
the hell bro open trash what have i ever done to you you
open trash no i like that it That's my teammate right there.
No, no, no.
Yeah, so we talked about prizes.
I talked about it on my stream.
Oh, my God, please.
I can't see.
Is this guy on Wi-Fi?
Is it me?
I can't tell.
I can't see.
You got a picture of the Evo for flight, hotel,
registration.
I mean, you could choose whether you're not.
You want to enter the tournament.
That's up to you.
You know, if you want to play in Tekken or some other games
of Evo, my fifth move is going to come in clutch.
Or it seems in first and second, they are from junk food.
And then we also have for third and fourth.
custom controllers Oh god please I'm sorry I'm so sorry for
doing that move we all sent you Chipotle code today I'm
sorry if you're in Canada by the way all right you're
Chipotle it's fine sorry about that but we also have
something for everybody there's a prize I'll be showing it
off on Sunday but we have something that we want to give
everybody participating and then everybody for participating
is also going to get some gifts up depending on where your
team places and something digital.
Oh god.
It's fine.
You can't duck this again because you don't learn.
Nobody learn.
Oh my gosh.
It's okay.
My fifth move right here.
Oh shit, okay.
My fifth move right.
Oh, never mind.
Oh my god, never mind.
I'm so sorry.
We're ready.
Let's game.
Good luck everybody.
Good luck.
I'm in the middle of the game!
Good luck gamers!
Oh god.
Okay.
And then...
And then I could do it again!
AHHHHH!
Without him like yelling in my ears.
Oh my gosh!
Hey everybody!
Sorry I'm like in the game.
Hey congrats on Dango Shure or whatever.
i did it i learned a fifth move and it's actually coming in
clutch what's your new move what do we uh low kick i just
spammed the low kick and then i'm spam the low kick into a
hop kick oh that's good oh wait do you have the hop kick
combo did you yeah yeah yeah i figured it out i learned good
i can't wait to see it now the question is can i use it in
like actual like on our players you're probably gonna get uh
obliterated by esam oh that guy hit purple that guy hit
purple everybody else i think you're good i think esam's a
try hard why the is he in my elo this match i don't know man
should be in the should be facing slime or you yeah i i
think they didn't expect them to get good so fast because
like it's his first time but but he comes from fighting
games like what yeah and he cares a lot, which means you
should put him high.
He should get, like, a handicap.
Or I should get the handicap.
If you win one round, it's over.
Yeah, exactly.
If I get one round, I win both sets.
That should be the handicap.
You guys talking about Shmish, ma'am?
Hell, yep.
It's not fair.
Why am I facing that guy?
he's it you got it what do you mean she does it listen she
does it it's okay what the fuck no dude he's purple yeah
what the fuck am i gonna do purple means nothing purple
means nothing no purple's really good actually yeah what do
you mean the coin is it cody purple that's where really good
players are they're really good though you're right you're
right purple means nothing that means you mean nothing cody
i think he sims gonna mash the hell out of you and there's
not gonna The law is just buttons.
He's just going to kick it.
But good luck.
Bro, am I even going to touch him?
My goal is to hit him one time.
You went two, three.
Oh, wait, did I went two, three?
I did.
Yeah, because he couldn't predict me because I didn't know
what I was doing.
So he didn't know what I was doing.
Hold on.
I got to shoot my shot something.
One second.
Whoa.
Oh my god, please, Alyssa, please.
Oh my god, I'm messing up.
Oh my god, I'm muting myself.
I got scared.
I thought I pictured her as ESAM.
Even though ESAM doesn't even play Alyssa.
I fucking hate Alyssa.
They're too fast!
You're too fucking fast!
fucking stop someone turn it off oh god it's okay oh my god
I can't do my special it's so true does anyone know how much
it is to buy tears in this game like in the battle pass no
right you're gonna spend money so there's a tulip at level
54 that goes on your head and myself a pickman and i want it
real bad but not if it's like 300 you know what i'm saying
like wait what how many tiers do you have to buy uh a lot um
let me see will increase battle pass by 20 that's 2 000
tokens if i do that'll be at 59 also apparently we're
supposed to join the lobby oh whoops all right one second
okay i just got here too oh welcome back how to coach yo
what's up you just spend your money you should do it 20
bucks for a picman dude okay but what about the content you
could put that on your thumbnail yeah you can use that your
thumbnail yes so for your highlights i and then the title be
i spent how much in techin eight
oh wait no i need it i need more than that because i need no
because i'm at I need to get to 56.
It would be dude.
That's expensive.
It's like 40 bucks.
Holy shit You'll earn it back on your YouTube highlights.
You'll earn it back Not on this video
That he's gonna rip off his shirt if you want Wait, why am I
playing against Sean?
I have to I have to activate good timeline.
I'm sorry.
It's just I need to see it happen Okay, okay.
Okay.
I'm back.
Why am I playing against Sean?
I don't know.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna...
That's not the match.
Yeah, this is not my match.
We didn't train for that guy.
Yeah, I didn't train for him.
I'm gonna play Eddie.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Please play King!
Okay.
Get in there!
Let's go!
I have Eddie locked in.
This is stage one, two.
two three i never play this character in my life let's go we
haven't even started this is a four fight isn't it kaiser's
oh my god yeah he's doing that thing oh i see what you mean
stay short so my god he's doing anything i do i thought you
meant like what to do
oh my god oh my god oh my god this is how people feel that's
what you do that's what i do oh my god oh no it's five
rounds please please what is happening i don't know secret
rule set that i wasn't aware of five rounds oh my god now i
know how other people feel when they play against me i know
it's a test round i don't understand what's happening i
don't know check i guess this is they uh yeah they
accidentally made a lobby with five yeah oh i've never seen
dots up there how high can it go that should be the finals
first is seven yeah first is seven a lot of adaptation going
on there oh my god you know what maybe king is bullshit okay
I mean he's definitely good
I didn't want people to know how I my fifth move.
I'll run to the bathroom, guys.
I should be here right now.
Oh, they're waiting for you to see.
Oh, yeah, he went to the bathroom.
Get him.
3-3-3-3-3-3-3-3-3-3.
I can't.
He's just grabbing me.
True.
Oh, my God.
truly unfair holy somebody nerf king please you know we
should really ban this character conic's like you know what
maybe i just play this guy it says he has a shotgun wait
where did he get the shotgun hammer into shotgun it's a it's
a cosmetic you can use it once yeah you can they're legal in
the tournament wait we should put wait how do i get a
shotgun don't do not i don't i don't i guess she's like
stacking her lips like you need a license you gotta wait
four days i'm from canada i don't i don't know how it feels
i'm from canada
i can't believe it he showed me what a true king player can
do he doesn't even play king what the i can't believe it
guys you know maybe king is bull shit chat maybe maybe king
was king is pretty bullshit
right to bear arms america you fuck yeah wait wait who are
you fighting okay i am i'm fighting a more i'm pretty sure
right where oh the why in the lobby a more wait oh right
right wait we're making a different why are we making a
different one oh yeah yeah yeah five rounds yeah five rounds
so we're gonna make a new one freaking kaiser man what the
heck oh my god you should have been making the lobby pro pro
yeah but he wasn't here wow so unprofessional i was telling
everyone that like if i lose any i blame you for lack of
team support yeah my morale is so low loud now because you
were late yeah i'm not gonna lie i've been late to pretty
much everything my whole life i swear dude if i lose we
blame brawl pro hold on i'm just learning something about
udoki it says someone said your fan base is called dragoons
yeah and it's shortened to goons yeah oh no Whoa, whoa,
whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Who told you that?
There's a double agent here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's nothing wrong with commanding an army of dudes.
Someone say it's a little bit respectable depending on how
you go about it.
Are you one of them?
Are you one of them, Matt?
Are you a Gooder?
He's on the inside.
on the inside he's on the inside he's been gooning
all right i'm losing i'm throwing every single one come on
hop hop bro oh wait this is he got caught wait why but the
shirtless i'm supposed to play i got so used to the shirt
the no shirt bought some clothes just popped into a store
yeah this is not a fit Oh, what is this?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I don't like this.
Now that she doesn't, now that she doesn't have a shirt, I
don't like this anymore.
You guys started right away?
Yeah.
Are we?
Yeah, I wasn't there either.
Are we, are we supposed to not start?
No, you're not.
No, no, no, no.
Fuck them up.
Cause I don't, I don't know anymore.
Oh, you rubbed up the docker Rudy!
Yay!
pull that shit down oh my god oh my god he's doing that
thing okay I've never seen that me too I've never seen that
either I was like what oh my god she's doing she's pulling
that off of me oh no way that hop kicks but she keeps hop
kicking I was supposed to hop kick this is not fair this is
my first game anyway and now i back up wait actually no i
don't now i go in oh shit oh my god my way i got it okay
let's go oh no you won yeah yeah i won that yeah i got she
lost me too i honestly thought so too i was so surprised one
more one more one more okay okay that's oh my god that was
not ready
perfect you're insane i told you the fifth move is all it
takes we're getting let's go it's the fifth move nobody
expects it it was it was unc being like here's a fifth one
and she was like it's like it's like a zelda game it comes
out of the chest and it's just your whole game plan yeah
that's what you're gonna use in the next boss yeah you gotta
use it everywhere yeah they've a plan for the fifth one they
never like mixed them up the mental stack is too high yeah
imagine if i learned a six move oh put your ass out of there
yeah you better take off your shirt wanted a turn you want
to get in on all the king action you know two two jaguars
and a bear and a we are We're gonna Eiffel Tower!
Slime!
Ah.
The goon accusations truly really held weight.
Oh my goodness, it might just be true.
Where the fuck is?
Where is Amore?
Wait!
She's gone!
Oh no, she's over there!
Slime get out!
He's just...
Slime really wants to play.
He's itching, man!
He heard about the...
He heard about the King sandwich.
learn he's that guy at the rotation that like plugs in
before anybody asks him to this is tournament bro he's like
yeah whatever he takes four puffs is this you take it like
you ever have somebody go like is this tournament you're
like yeah and they're like all right and they sit down
anyway like they're gonna play after what what do you yeah
they jg shake my hand they tell the to you one i mean i
don't mind if he plays for me oh my god thank you i was like
oh my god jk i had a secret six move this is like the
millennia's naked phase two the king scarlet rot oh no oh no
any wizards oh okay the fifth move there we go
Anyway, only only that one should only be done by
profession.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait.
No Oh, that would have been humongous.
Okay.
Yeah, remove the sixth move stick to the fifth one.
Oh, but it's so funny You know what maybe keep doing Maybe
keep doing it You guys didn't believe
Why didn't you believe?
My fault, my fault.
It's like you put three, mama, but you put in five eggs.
Eggs, eggs, eggs.
It's the same thing.
Exactly.
But he doesn't, they don't learn.
That's the thing.
This is a delicious omelet.
Oh my god.
They had the answer and then they stopped having the answer.
And now they remember it again.
I don't understand.
Why do they...
No, no, they downloading me.
Oh, what the fuck?
King versus king.
What the fuck?
Do it now.
Yeah, okay.
It's okay.
I stepped.
Yes, and then I do the six moves.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, my God.
I don't think that was, that cannot be intentional.
There's no way.
That's right.
I did the square.
oh my goodness oh no we blocked that oh yeah yeah yeah oh
but then she did this to me no but she keeps doing stuff do
that what what you know what okay that's all right okay
they're both so angry i know stop being so angry move number
seven move number seven oh wait but she like figured it out
she think she's figuring it out though no no i mean i okay
stop stop you're looking at me yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
what the fuck probably the best It works.
Backyard wrestling.
It works.
What the hell, dude?
They don't learn.
I keep spamming it as long as they don't learn.
That was still insane.
I don't understand, though.
They did learn.
They unlearned.
They unlearned it.
They just, okay, it's because they think I would stop doing
it, but I'm so stubborn that I kept doing it.
They were so surprised.
That was crazy.
They're like, she eventually will stop, right?
But I didn't, because I was more stubborn.
is all about well done okay i have a real question you get
hit by five alley kicks and your character is like who the
fuck is this guy is that good i think that's one of your
fans in here we need some attention right now you're
remaking it because um because it was first to one oh eyes
are taking oh my god bad lobbies wait so i didn't even need
to win that second set no you did but but you did you did oh
guys went back to the victory conditions oh all right nice
that was so fucking easy you got you got your one dub ski i
got my one dub i don't have to win again i already i already
have surpassed super's record so i don't need to do anything
anymore is the lobby broke for anybody else yeah it's broken
uh i can try to make I don't trust your lobbies, bro.
Arata, give us Waffle House.
Dude, what are you supposed to do?
We might as well just get C-Jammed and make the lobby.
Kaiser keeps having to edit his code.
He keeps posting a lobby and then having to edit it.
What?
He can't do it.
That he didn't mean.
How do you edit a link?
Like, in the Discord, he keeps, like, posting the link and
then screwing it up.
He's, oh, my bad.
Did he post the right one?
Yeah.
We have a password.
password now with the weight all right and we can show the
password to everybody because because it's like yeah it
doesn't matter we learned that today all right I'm gonna go
to the bathroom while we while everybody files in all right
let's go what did they talk about in the orientation when I
was like running late they were like wow bra pros late yeah
it wasn't it wasn't big they actually did call
you and said sage m has a hair system which he does whoa i
didn't pay attention i was like an fgc like inside thing
that no one talks about but i'm breaking this news live
today all right he has a hair system and he's bald in real
life nice i know it's not nice no i mean not nice
oh my god we already got points look at me go we're already
running it up we're already a positive record all right guys
don't fuck it up now i worked very hard for that lead those
five alley kicks i worked very hard for it points points
points points all right if i get on that goddamn wall stage
again i'm randoming off That's crazy, dude.
Do you think, like, you could get away with five alley kicks
on Dwayne's turn?
No, no.
I might do it.
I might do it, but I don't think I'm going to get away with
it.
Try.
Try for the one time.
Five alley kicks and the hop kick.
I believe.
Looking like he's fucking Warrong.
I was going to say that wall is so good.
Like, if the back is to the wall.
Okay, thank God we're on arena.
Fine with me.
Don't you like.
uh the dojo oh because the wall who's that josey round one
oh i look the costume yeah that's like coding oh my god each
time reina oh oh nice meeting in hawaii on the beach oh my
god she's into that jaguar dick wait what gig agree it's
okay Nice.
Wow.
I mean, you're just beautiful, handsome, beautiful.
I see a wall.
Beautiful a third time.
You see a wall.
Take you to the wall.
Alley kick to the wall.
We bought those.
I see the wall.
Nice.
Oh, the alley kick!
Okay, so he's sidestepping every time to stop the first
thing.
Oh, pay attention.
You weren't paying attention, coach.
I...
Sorry, there's a lot of people in the chat.
Oh wow, chat over team, I understand.
Oh, I see, I see.
Yeah.
All right, fine.
I don't know when to get out there or how to get out when in
that spot.
Don't pull dick jabs in your diet.
Yeah, you're right.
We'll be good.
Okay, so...
Yeah, yeah, that's always going to be a mid.
That's always going to be a mid when he crashes.
He's always going to be a mid when he crashes.
but oh this guy oh oh my god oh my god oh nice nice you got
out does he know how to get up he's ducking he does not nice
yeah he's ducking we're gonna teach you that that's a free
follow-up guaranteed damage oh nice my seventh he's gonna
sidestep yeah your seventh move is a guaranteed move
what a hot cake i mean you just read people like that it's
just a simple thing
Oh my god.
I mean, talk about improvements.
Oh, that's funny as hell.
Lab the matchup, reapply, boom, dead.
That easy.
I'm going to be just like that tomorrow.
He's just blocking mids.
He beat me yesterday just by midding.
If I just like beat that.
He might just start with sidestep again, just autopilot.
I'm going to see.
He does.
He like his 4-4-2 into the high.
You can duck a second hit of them.
damn oh my god oh nice oh my god the shoulder we ran the
shoulder drill we ran the shoulder drill take her back to
that wall oh my god one alley kick that's all you need
beautiful person i've ever met oh my god that was perfect
he's now also good with the food pyramid you can't have too
many but sometimes it's a treat oh he's he's so good
dispenser you're in his mind
Nice.
That's all right.
Yeah, okay.
So we're setting up for grab a long time, just waiting for
me to stand.
Oh.
Nice.
No!
Okay, whatever.
Wait, wall?
Never mind.
He might block alley kick here.
No.
Oh, nice!
The alley kick!
Hey, don't listen to me, man.
To keep alley kick.
Like I didn't listen and I got my five alley kicks.
I don't know how.
Oh my god, the shoulder.
Andy just to set up another knee.
Like look at that.
Run him so broke over.
Okay, they're not going to get hit by this in two days.
That's too obvious.
Knee shoulder guarantee.
I blocked mids.
The game is over.
This should have happened two days ago.
The king streak.
Wrap it up, dude.
This should have happened two days ago.
I blocked your mids.
You're not playing.
So these points add on to the points from two days ago.
ago so this is making the gap wider between our team and
this team they're the second they're worth five points
instead of three yeah oh nice okay uh all right wait which
team's the second team and what well uh tony's and nyk's
teams i think they were tied for a second actually so it was
very close nice yeah it's tony's and nyk's team uh that are
the scariest who is this guy
the dragoon 671 all right is this not private what the fuck
how did this person get in here again it was in the last one
too yeah yeah how did this person get in we not ban him or
kick him uh i think it's kaiser all right there you go you
kick there we go oh there you go that does he keep getting
in i don't know how he's getting in yeah your turn old
gooner oh i gotta get bro he's hacking the system all right
uh slime remember that he does a little two hit dance thing
he likes to go low after that's a while sending four if you
block it okay all right and we finish our combos and i mean
didn't you beat them didn't you i beat them last time but it
was close clown world yeah it was i remember it and uh yeah
he falls for the barrel electric a lot when you just keep
repeating it So I don't know if he still will.
So ready.
Okay.
Got this, man.
Get ready for the next battle.
Let's go.
I almost wore that same thing today.
What he's wearing now?
That should look like a Pop-Tart.
Oh my god, that's what I'm talking about.
That's what I'm fucking talking about.
Oh, I'm definitely behind you guys.
He'll be a great one for sure.
Round two, fight.
There's a strong button.
Nice.
Oh.
Good.
Oh, that's good.
Damn it.
That was kind of war on it.
You had hate slime.
Keep that in mind.
Whoops.
Round three.
Fight.
Oopsie.
I didn't mean to do that.
All right.
I got a fire.
Panic here.
Big.
Oh Oh Oh nice Beautiful combo really He's stuck Just let him
out Let him out dude He's just in the fucking corner Wait in
the corner!
Don't let him breathe!
Nice!
Round 4 Fight
What the fuck is the whole play?
I've never seen that large move called upon Zeus.
That's his key.
It's like a mini jack.
Nice punish.
That's what I'm talking about.
Good shit.
One more round, brother.
Oh my god, I'm so behind.
We just start with a little hop.
Oh my goodness.
We're getting real cute now.
That's all good.
Oh Wow, that is fucking crazy.
Oh, what?
Oh, no way!
Wait, did you guys, did he win?
Mental shatter.
He won!
Oh my god, I'm still watching him beat him up.
It's just the reverse 3-0, like a mull in this opulent
mansion.
Oh, man.
Good shit, man.
Good reverse.
fight
Nice All
right, you're still ahead he whips that's good chip.
I top kick Oh, nice.
What the fuck is that is that unblockable?
Yeah, it's an unblockable you can twin fist on him before he
gets to
Yeah, yeah, yeah Nice!
He missed!
Very nice.
Oh, okay.
Round two.
Oh, he's lovely.
By his large dress like Mr. Beast Chocolate.
She's pretty close.
It's true.
He is.
Feastables.
Beastables.
Bro, look at Mighty Feastable right now, bro.
Mr. Beast sponsored us.
Okay, I don't know.
He was just doing...
He did neutral there.
I don't know what that is.
Right.
It's Samus near.
I keep left here.
Easy.
Nice.
Whatever.
But it's okay.
Drop your American reset.
That's what we call that slime.
Reset.
An actual American reset.
You guys low here?
He knew.
You have heat.
Oh, nice.
Nice flip.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
One more, brother.
This guy learned how to mix and hunt the bear stance.
It's over.
That's all.
20 right there.
Close.
We dropped?
I hate him.
I'm so pathetic.
It's so pathetic character.
He plays pathetically.
I agree with that.
Stop using heat, you pussy.
Nice.
He's a docker.
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Mold with a salmon!
Most blessed sidewall I've ever seen in my life.
What a lovely bear.
You got this cool sidewall last time too.
I think it was against him.
That's an actual...
He fell into the bear enclosure.
It just got pushed.
And they were like, where's his family?
He's like, oh, someone, please.
Bro, I couldn't get out.
He loved Mr. Beast.
Oh, my God.
That was so stressful.
Good shit, dude.
When he won rounds, he fucking won rounds, too.
It was really scary.
Lars is just kind of steam-roly.
He'll do that.
Like, he just runs you over.
Good shit.
I didn't use back- Yeah, you downloaded him.
Slime, everything we talked about, bro.
You are doing that shit with purpose.
I know.
Oh, that makes me so happy.
I'm gonna keep it a hundred dot like I know we're having fun
But you're a really fucking good coach like I'm serious Even
beyond like you know the meme shit like seriously I'm gonna
say last night was sick Yeah, you managed to teach me a
fifth move.
That's fucking insane Yeah, we're cooking Oh, yeah, dude get
his ass Matt Let's get it, Jack Jesus Real shit no Yakushima
is a breath of fresh air for shifter right now yeah this is
shifter uh rage quit last time okay yeah for him in the
mansion i think he's like learning now how do you even do
jack practice you got to call up anakin yeah red bull anakin
red bull anakin for a hundred dollars an hour this is crazy
dude oh my god don't make him i'm playing in the beginning
of the round Oh, no!
Bro doesn't know where he's shooting.
Is there a duck here?
Oh, he's tilted.
You can tell us.
Yeah, I would be pissed if I had to play against that man's
Jack 8.
Yeah, like he already won the trip to evil.
Why is he here again?
That's what I'm saying.
What the fuck is his problem, man?
Holy shit.
Oh, what is that whiff, monkey the animal?
Range 5 whiff.
I don't think he's thinking anymore.
Not going to lie.
That's too much damage, dude.
He's a big boy.
I'm done.
I'm rooting for shifter now.
Holy shit.
Just to balance things out.
Okay.
He gets around.
I got auto balance to the other team.
Oh wait, is he gonna take a round off?
He took a round off you!
Okay, we are blocking.
Oh my god.
Okay That is insane But all he can do is block.
He's a force Drop the stab.
That's right.
Don't even need it.
Don't even oh my god.
It ended fast It doesn't fucking end, man.
Doki, how are you delayed if you're in the lobby with us?
I don't know.
That's so weird.
Yeah, you're getting spoiled by the screaming.
You're gonna have to restart tech and everything.
I think so, yeah.
You guys were like, end to Sam, like, she's still playing.
Dude is doing strings!
Oh, her PC is potato.
Matt, you know that two hits, the string he did before he
did a low heat smash?
The second hit is a high.
Oh.
Big mistake.
That's in the commandments.
Every time.
Oh.
Time to be punished.
Half bar.
To let her get up.
Oh my god.
What a gamma health.
What the fuck?
is this it's my turn it's his turn forever launch you can
launch that just like nope reverse i like the idea
oh they were killing slime with that
did he know he's No way.
Bounce?
It's a guard break.
You can't block it.
I do.
Okay.
It'll be a miracle of shifter that makes it to Sunday.
I would destroy my PC.
This is insane.
What if he's at bar go?
What if, like, we get the buy?
Where is his bar?
Bro, we looked away for five seconds of the skull of his
guys.
Oh my god, two seconds.
This is fucking unfair.
This character is insane.
Blood, where are you?
Easy.
Oh my god, dude.
I think we ruined his day.
He has like four more rounds to go.
Yeah, that's a joke.
Yeah, that's a hard joke.
How will you face the other four opponents?
Uh...
You know what, Brawl Pro?
That's a 4-0 sweep.
you win yeah yeah keep it keep it going yeah but surely guys
your king players you wouldn't let us down right coach i'm
laughing for all you guys yesterday i don't have time right
coach like i laughed for four people in one day how when am
i gonna laugh for myself can you let it for me okay okay but
we played me on my way you said i i literally dm'd you i
said hey i'm having trouble with this you're like go check
the vaude and then you left me alone I was with slime when
you sent that.
I'm like, four people, my ass, bro.
Okay, three people.
You literally sent me on my way.
You're like, nah, that's good.
Yeah, you're old.
Here's $20.
Order a pizza.
You're old enough to take care of your ass.
That's what I'm saying.
That's how he treats my ass.
Hot dogs in the sink.
This fucking guy, man.
He just looks like they did it all.
Matt, you call me broke yesterday.
It's just payback.
Oh, my goodness.
Round one.
Now the chat spam is a broke.
Like, what is that?
Okay.
I love that move.
Oh.
Nice.
Do the alley kicks.
Yeah, the alley kick is guaranteed.
That's guaranteed.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah.
Round two.
Oh, okay.
I see.
Damn.
Wow.
It's not a good look if you're the only one that doesn't win
a round, bro.
It's not a good look.
The coach doesn't win for us after all the points we got for
him.
He's late and he loses.
And he loses?
Wait, unless...
Oh, that's what I'm talking about.
Oh.
That guy just knows.
Look at like slime out there.
I feel like the more we roast him, the better he does, guys.
He needs to prove us wrong!
The nothing?
Damn, he's agile!
Dude, the higher level Tekken gets, the more people just run
up to do nothing.
It's so scary.
You're just like, what is he gonna do?
Pop, pop, pop, and it's gaming.
All right, all right, all right.
My fault, coach.
Uh-oh.
I'm so bad at the game.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Oh, no.
Rage art?
No.
Rage art, we win.
Let's go!
Oh my god, don't worry, I'm going to see the Rage art soon.
I'm going to armor this black-ass mix-up.
Guys, don't worry.
He's rage-arting now.
Baby
Kaiser was definitely starting to feel himself He was like
Oh watch this straight And then you just wait Wave That's
nice Nice God I'm so behind Good shit One more bro It's okay
I'll do my best boys I saw the rage art just then guys Round
1 Nice Fight Boom Good shit The coach doesn't know?
The coach doesn't know?
Oh, this is it.
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh, no!
What a fucking giant swing, bro.
Send it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yes!
He teabagged.
That's our coach.
That's the values he teaches us.
learn how to teabag from my coach.
He told me to do it after every game.
Please stop.
Slime, you've seen Billy Madison, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We're the O'Doyles.
That's this team.
We're just the fucking O'Doyles.
This doesn't bode well if we get to the very end of the
movie.
Let's avoid Buster.
Wait, what happens at the end of the movie?
What happens?
Don't worry about it.
Is it good thing?
Oh, the Doyle rule.
Elsa air!
Whoa!
Okay, no problem.
Oh, you got cocky there.
Anti-air, anime fighter.
What the fuck?
You just kicked her.
Yeah, it's a low grab.
You gotta hold down back to attack it.
Oh my god.
You just wanted to make it close for content.
That's it.
Oh, good shit.
Boom, boom.
Punishable.
You love a juicy hot kick.
Imagine.
Oh.
Nice.
Guess we're game.
What is that?
Oh, boy.
Oh, what?
How come we weren't taught that move?
It's too dangerous.
We would kill ourselves doing it.
We'd break our neck.
It's actually too much power.
for you guys final technique only when you're a god you can
do this
damn it oh okay i see okay okay oh one more said come on
coach you got this being the matrix let's what download it
let's go
one day we'll all be a hundred daniels where did that come
from i'm only 30 daniels not i think i'm 20 days how do you
get a hundred days they just give you 70 daniels after you
get you got oh you get the 30 and they just yeah they're
just too many daniels in the world gotta adopt them adopt
don't shop oh get up get up coach come on coach get up
they're beating your ass oh oh nice what the fuck is that oh
dude smell this dick
Oh, yes, sir.
Oh, does?
She's screaming the whole time.
Wait, stop!
Oh, I hate this!
Oh, no.
Oh, nice!
Oh, no, she took you to the wall.
Damn it.
No problem, no problem.
It's okay.
You bring it back.
Smash a beer bottle.
What a close block.
The punish.
Kaiser might be gaming.
You know, we're just giving them false sense of security.
Nice.
Okay.
You get wall, you get everything.
Oh, we love holding back.
Yes!
Yeah!
We don't hit any buttons!
No buttons!
Fight!
Oh my god.
Nice dick punch.
Oh, I didn't know what the second hit was.
Oh.
Yeah.
That might be it.
Oh, yeah.
Damn, GG.
Oh, GG's.
Oh, I tried.
I tried.
Ah.
It's okay.
We just wanted to give them one extra point, you know?
We felt bad.
Yeah, it makes sense.
Yeah.
You gave us all a shard of yourself, Brawl Pro.
Across the team, because it's just mathematically better,
you know?
Yeah.
We add all of us together as one Brawl Pro.
I'm okay getting carried by my team.
I'm okay with that.
Bro, it's like the Ninja Turtles getting care like splinter
like taking care of those babies and now he's the old
splinter And we're the new Ninja Turtles.
I'm Raphael though.
I won't be Raphael.
That's why I just Leonardo will call it You guys don't have
the other two Sorry, sorry that there's two shitty Ninja
Turtles.
Yeah, I'm Donatello.
Okay, there we go That means that's the party dude
It doesn't work out any better.
It's perfect.
I actually liked Donatello when I was a kid because I
thought he was the smartest and I thought that was
important.
Yeah, that's why I'm Donatello.
But not now?
No, now I just, I want to be like the Chad Leonardo with
swords.
Sure.
Wait, doesn't matter?
Yeah, doesn't matter is Mikey, Michelangelo.
That just makes sense.
That makes sense.
Literally, I couldn't ask for a better circle.
Because I know he can never be Donatell
Alright, we got a stack before the next round So if you guys
want to run a Nice We can chill Yeah, I got to do a quick
match I'm feeling kind of Yeah, I'm going to restart my tech
in Because I'm 80 fucking seconds behind Yeah, you promised
you'd hook up your new computer Now you're still on Potato
Island In the finals Look, it's because It's like those
training weights So when the weights are finally off For the
finals, I'm unstoppable Yeah, right?
that's how it goes like not 20 fps you're like oh my god you
see the matrix i see an 800 frames that'll be good uh who's
next i don't know who do we play we play against let's look
at our team brawl pro chat bro it's god or good oh that's
awesome good dough i'm fighting a uh an ace attorney uh
dragon of he has like the mask and everything we're fighting
tone next all right team as box blocks he could beat me 100%
I played him a lot last night
yeah how did he feel he's getting up there he's getting
better for sure
guys I swear for the finals the PC will be plugged in it's
just backing up I swear
for real this time for real chat i would never lie to you
are you watching the mainstream or i'm just on a i'm not
quick matching because i feel rest i swear it's gonna be
there but it was i'm gonna have it set up before the finals
so by the time the finals roll up i'm be a god that king
that doesn't mean she'll use it it's unboxed the first step
is over I completed the first step is that what matters yeah
I completed the first step
This guy's pretty good, but his offense is kind of weak.
The frames will be back soon, guys.
It'll be back soon.
Don't worry.
I'm loading in.
See, there you go.
I was loading in the shaders.
I was loading in.
I'm loading in more shaders.
See, duck that one time, but not other times.
I don't expect people to mix up.
The shaders are loading up, guys.
There we go.
It's fine now, see?
Now it's fine.
Now you can see everything.
There.
It's fine.
If he just waits and then does that, I don't talk to him
every time.
See, look.
It's smooth.
It's so smooth, chat.
But this is my favorite move now.
This is honestly...
I haven't done that yet.
I think it hits wall.
This cat let go.
This is my favorite move, chat.
And then I can do the hop kick.
The perfect move.
That's how I got to this Elo.
The best move ever.
Nobody can fucking counter it for some reason.
why wait this guy has this this guy is on wi-fi look this
guy's wi-fi he deserves to have the frames he deserves the
treatment i'm putting him through with my apc no please i'm
sorry i did not mean that please i'm so sorry i was joking i
did not mean that all right oh my god goodbye he broke my
arm no see the frames are okay now it's okay see look
everything is fine you guys can see everything it just takes
a bit to load it in okay watch this and then and there oh
wait what the fuck wait sir sir you're supposed to let me do
a hop kick that wasn't what the alley kicks are for oh shit
okay guys it's not looking so good
Boop.
He ducked.
He cheated.
Ducky in front of a king player?
What the fuck is wrong with him?
What is wrong with this man?
How dare you?
Here we go.
He's not gonna duck again.
They never learn.
They never learn when they play against a king.
It's fine.
Oh, wait.
Oh, he overheard me.
Not.
It's fine.
This time.
Whoa.
No, it's not fine.
I'm so sorry.
Let me go.
There's no way.
And then my secret hidden six move that nobody knows yet.
Until the finals.
Then people are going to know in the finals.
That's fucking right.
No more over.
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
I did not expect that.
Not gonna lie.
Please, please, please.
Give me that.
Please.
Oh.
Give me that one hit.
Oh, that's scary.
It's fine.
And then...
And then it's my turn.
Right?
Is it my turn?
It is.
Yay!
You bitch.
You whore.
Okay, it's fine.
There you go.
And again!
No!
He's sorry!
Nobody loves you!
Not even your mom!
Okay, I'm so sorry.
I'm so...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get closer, please.
Oh.
The sides.
There you go.
See?
We did it.
Yay!
God!
How did I hit?
Because I called him Loveless.
I called him a Loveless Child.
And that's how it hits.
I've become a fighting game gamer.
That's how it works.
If you hit.
If you tell your enemy nobody.
loves him.
He'll get hurt emotionally and then you win.
The one button rage.
Alright, stay the win.
Get one and done.
Exactly.
He's not special.
He's not the only one and done.
It's okay, guys.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm loading in the shaders.
It'll be fine.
See?
I told you.
It's fine.
I had to load in the shaders.
there yeah oh okay nice I don't know how that hit too but
I'll take it yo wait wait I never expect people to counter
that we try to we try to say the higher that you know the
more easily I can counter oh shit okay Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh No, no Please, ah
I'm sorry I'm so sorry JK, I'm not sorry Cause you don't, he
ducked JK I'm still not sorry Cause I don't learn I don't
learn That's fucking right Yeah Okay, is he gonna hit?
No, he's not.
Oh, whoa.
It's fine.
Oh, he fucking ducked that?
How?
Bro, he just walks away.
You don't walk away from me.
Oh, my God.
How do you just walk away?
How do you lose?
Just turn around and walk away.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He keeps...
he he keeps walking away from me i don't know what to do
surprised me because you face he just he just walks it's
insane i don't know how he does it the spacing just turn
around you know just fucking turn around don't duck oh thank
god okay don't duck as well oh oh oh nice nice no i fucked
it up but it's for perfect
i fucked it up but it doesn't matter goodbye
goodbye yay We won that, the reason why we're not in the
game yet, another, in the next round yet, is that we won the
game so fucking fast that, like, uh, we won our set so fast,
um, that we're just chilling now.
We're just pracked, warming up.
When nothing works, AliKick, exactly.
Oh, we're just waiting.
How are you so good?
Because I don't need to learn, like, 20 plus moves.
I just learned, like, four to six, and then just perfect.
it they can't predict it because like I also throw in random
button mashing so they can never predict it because it's
like which one is like they don't know when like is the real
match you know if I throw in random button mashing they
can't predict the moves oh my god bro okay oh my god she
stopped it She actually... She's gonna block this, isn't
she?
Goodbye.
Look, she's red-ranked.
She knows how to do it.
When I learn a seventh move, I can beat her.
That's all I'm saying.
The moment I learn a seventh move, I can beat her.
Oh, my God.
She fucking stuck.
Just saying, the fifth and sixth move got me to this Elo.
Not gonna lie.
The fifth and sixth move got me here.
Jesus!
Holy fuck!
Gotta start throwing up mid.
Yay!
Bop-bop.
Goodbye!
Yay!
That was so close.
Is she gonna...
Yeah.
Oh, she is.
Oh, I thought she was gonna duck.
That's not fair.
She didn't.
Why didn't you duck?
Why did you duck?
Why?
Oh, now you duck!
Okay, I did mean now.
Don't stop ducking!
I didn't mean now!
I can't believe it Oh my god Now she does that Bro
Why don't you duck when I don't want you to duck Bitch There
you go Fuck off!
Fuck off!
Um, what the heck is a passcode?
Oh no, we're starting.
Oh no, please.
Please, I'm getting juggled so hard right now, please.
Please get close to me.
That's right!
Give me a sec!
Yeah!
Leave your elo!
I'm gonna learn my seventh move!
And you're going down.
The Reds are going down.
When I learned my seventh move.
That's right.
Doki's coming.
The Red Rings.
You're going down.
Yay.
Yippee.
Apparently matches.
Okay.
I'm like what am I one game off of red yellow.
Oh team.
You guys have to join the lobby.
No No, no Okay, I just I just beat a red ranker.
All right.
All right, all right, bro.
I got a seven win streak I'm so close.
Oh my god.
I get promo Are you fucking joking?
Are you on promo?
I'm nine points off promo I think I'm gonna restart my
computer after this make them wait for us so you can get
your rank I'm literally nine points off promo that's insane
oh my god all right here we go the ears don't go up oh sorry
oh e sam does a lot of slide from mid-range you remember
that totally
guys it doesn't matter if i show the password all my other
teammates showed their password already so like i hide it it
doesn't matter my teammates are showing the password so it
doesn't matter the code is right here I'm here I'm ready
okay so what does Isam do again remember when you played him
last time he did the slide a lot he did the slide where it
was low from mid screen do I just block low do I block I
don't remember.
I'm so scared.
So what do I do?
Coach, what do I do?
Wait, our coach left.
Well.
Like, why are you even from left and joined SageM?
You didn't even tell me what to do.
Well, Jason, you as per usual, I see.
He didn't even tell me what to do.
I can't believe it.
I guess I'll never know what to do.
Our coach went out to get milk, guys.
Yeah, he'll come back.
He'll come back, right?
Surely he'll come back.
He'll come back to coaches, right, guys?
He sounds not going to know my low kick.
He won't expect it.
I think we're just waiting for them, for, uh, casters to be
ready at the moment, chat.
So we're just waiting for now.
We're just waiting for now.
All right, I'm back team.
Sorry, they yoyed me for an interview.
So, so what do I do?
Oh, man.
Um, you gotta, uh, Okay, so if he's mid-range, he's going to
maybe do the slide.
The punish on the slide might be annoying to just explain
here because you have to, like, crouch cancel and then do
the down forward.
What?
Wait, crouch cancel?
Okay, you just, if you block the slide, just alley kick him
three times.
Okay.
That's a punish.
All right.
I got it.
in three times i know how to do that and after the third
alley kick hit hit the right punch it's a fourth hit so that
will also okay the right punch okay or you can yeah you can
also just while standing four like if you block low like
then just hit four to do the while standing four oh no he's
doing the thing who's watching this who can spectate oh my
god sam please I'm surprised like, I hate fighting this guy
in rank as well, too.
Oh my God, you know he's purple, he can duck.
Okay, you gotta hit him with the elbow when you're
sprinting.
Yeah, he knows how to duck.
So I have to, do you think he'll duck this?
Yes.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Goodbye.
Cruel world.
The law is loud.
Oh my god.
This ass is just screaming.
That's why I'm watching this shit muted, dude.
The law is annoying.
I hate playing against law in general, even in rank.
It's so annoying.
Oh my god, he just sucks everything.
It's like he's been playing against king players such a hard
life.
Hey guys, it was great.
existing.
I existed.
You know, it went the way I expected it to go.
That's all right.
It's all right.
He's a nerd.
He is.
He's a fucking nerd.
We already talked about this.
He wants the trip so bad.
Oh my god, how does he, why do I fall?
This character does a lot of stuff.
Oh, yes.
That's fucking right.
He did a trick for my alley kicks.
Let's freaking go.
I got that.
It's fine.
That's a mighty ruler.
This guy's purple.
He lets me alley kick him 20 times.
Like, come on, bro.
that's what i'm talking about that's what i'm talking about
oh no that's not that's not it guys guys you jason you're
alive for a while i was it was actually crazy i've not been
alive for that long the worst part is like i i hate being on
the right side hey we're live don't give him the don't don't
give him the day oh jk i can pull me both sides i'm
ambidextrous i'm not though oh god what does he do i don't
know do you know i don't know i'm pushing buttons hell yeah
let's click on click more of them let's go oh what he
blocked that you so told me he wouldn't well if he blocks it
then you grab a master you told me he doesn't block those
Hold up.
It's okay.
I got that one round.
Remember, I got one round off of purple.
You can do it.
That should be worth some points.
Yeah, that should be like, weird.
At least like one point.
Because he's literally smurfing at this point.
Give us something.
Hey guys.
I did not exist there.
One point.
Give us one point.
My handicap.
That's fine.
He's cheating, so...
honestly the slide seems not fair i think a nerf is in order
i think so too i got herada on the line i got him on hold
because i'm busy so if i can't spectate do i have to restart
the lobby or the game that's so annoying are you the one who
made that lobby no i think it was tony so you can't even
join uh i'll just watch on say jams stream no give me the
view there's you're delayed you're delayed the i'm not
anymore restarted my techin i swear i swear okay you still
can't break it uh let's see here i cannot winds up round one
and co-means obviously yep we should restart the match
because Hell yeah.
Ooh!
I got that for him.
Oh my god, you bit his dick!
Ah, that sucks.
Okay.
Remember, Kony, you can challenge that.
The down two.
Yeah.
Freaky dragon.
Is blue higher than purple?
Yeah, blue is higher.
Okay.
Not by much.
Oh my goodness, we labbed.
let's go with the duck oh guaranteed a three three is good
yeah i know huge forgot 24 next time yeah alley kick alley
kick dude i'm holding back okay i feel like i'm holding back
there okay you got it you got it island jconi someone said
you got this
grab yeah oh yes yes nice tech nice i don't think that hits
oh you're so good oh what oh yeah i didn't think that would
land oh my god that's funny that the land is easy rage art
oh come on Raid dart.
He fucking texts.
Wow.
Get him.
Raid dart after back one too.
Go.
Okay.
Alright, cool, cool.
Yeah!
Round four.
Fight.
Oh,
you're such a goat!
You know what the fuck to do?
Nice!
Oh my god.
You press?
What a fucking monkey.
What the hell?
Yeah, that was a gorilla.
Why'd he raise her?
He had a mix of.
He didn't need that.
All right.
Yeah!
They're reversed, are they?
Fight.
Oh, they go block.
Oh, he's so freaky and weird.
Really?
Yeah, counter hit.
Okay.
Like, I know what to do.
I'm just not fucking doing it.
Yeah.
When that down to you hits while sending four he's mashing
after it yeah okay it was very close that's the only
adjustment you need i think it's literally just that you
know round one fight not on counter hit though yeah oh
my god Yeah.
Oh my god.
God, it's the sweet fucking thing.
Great.
Dude!
It's okay.
Nine.
adapt adapt
yeah oh my god yeah dragon house crazy dragon stone bullshit
yeah yeah i don't know man it's just fucking yeah that's
right i had i had something and it's like i don't know
that's all right we run some drills yeah just don't problem
we gotta play freaky josh now freaky it's a whole it's
actually an entire freaky team it's just so hard to predict
it's okay our teammates will win this for us guys
i believe
this is the second is this team second or third uh second
okay I think yeah yeah this team's right below us okay but
they're tied I think for a second though if I'm not mistaken
I think it's like one point above right is Kyle Delgado an
op yeah I don't know who this guy is nor do I know who Zin
Megami Tensei is that's Josh oh I don't know who Kyle
Delgado is yeah probably just like a streamer guy yeah just
gotta kick him that's annoying someone kick kyle no one's
gonna play you bro
someone kick kyle
wait what's the passcode what one nine one nine yeah it
doesn't matter doesn't matter like everybody's seen the
passcode already i bet you can see in sayjam's stream too
Josh man readied up is fucking stupid he's the stupidest
person I think I've ever met in my whole life ever ranked
ranked number one on the PR
did someone leak the code the code is on screen yeah like
what does he mean wait see Jeff actually hides the passcode
oh it's our fault I guess
not my screen
so we all got a oh god wait this is why he's secretly bald
do we actually have to hide the code look guys hf want us to
censor the code somehow i don't have the elements in my obs
we just get a picture like put a white bar over it i don't
have the element
Blackbar.png.
Yeah.
Wait, so what's happening?
How do I get in?
For...
Oh, I see.
I see.
All right.
We're going.
Your rage art button, brother.
So rage art.
Remember, slime, when he back ones, he generally likes the
back one again right after.
So you can maybe g-cliff that a couple times.
And then he's going to start back-onning into the 1-2
strings, which will beat your g-cliff.
So if you're making the read, you can just hold back and be
safe.
Or you can down back four for a huge call out because
that'll crush the high, I think.
But, I mean, if you just hold back against Brian, he can
only hit you with his hatchet.
And I guess, like, his wall stuff.
But, I mean, depends on the stage for the wall stuff, pretty
much, though, you know.
Holding back, definitely more safe.
Yeah.
Yup.
The walls are good for you as well.
Yeah, good luck, boss.
You got this.
Can bear a break floor easy?
Round one.
Good shit.
Take him to the wall.
What a hop kick.
Oh.
That's why I remember when he's pressuring you, he bursts as
a free get out of jail card for you.
Okay.
Yeah!
No, do not mistake again.
Dude,
what?
Oh my god!
Back 2-2-1 with a combo.
Back 2-2-1.
Oh!
Nice.
Oh, what?
Good chance, Lou.
Oh my god.
Can't believe that.
Connected.
Now this is bad.
Nice.
Good block, Josh.
All right.
No more cell sweeps.
Bro, full crash down forward one, so I'm gonna save.
Yep.
Should I punish that forward one, so I'm gonna stay.
Oh.
Round three.
Nice.
that in a hundred years a lot of chip nice oh bummer damn
get off the healer that's fine i mean you're hitting him a
lot of damage though you don't have to worry about it
anymore yep he's gonna pop heat and probably blow heat smash
by the way i'm just gonna chill
oh my god
good g club doing work let's go okay man let's go
Nice.
Good orbital.
Good orbital, Josh.
Okay.
Nice.
Good shit.
Got him.
Oh, God.
I can't see it yet.
But I'm... Good job.
One more.
Okay, that was sick, though.
I just got to it.
Nice
grab.
Wow.
Okay.
Good shit.
They're electric.
Another bounce.
Hell yeah.
Got him.
that full crowd yeah okay full crowd one
i thought i'd get crazy with it nice orbital josh you're
such a goat he runs in the room fucking smack nice grab
all right no more autopilot how do i get up and block that i
keep fucking is it Or is that true?
That might be real.
I'm not very clear.
It might be.
I'm not sure.
We can lab it tonight.
You can hit up and down.
Oh, beautiful.
I'm going to see it soon.
Oh, I saw it.
Yeah, I'm like 14 seconds.
Sick fucking head.
Oh.
Oh, he's backing.
He's scared.
what good duck whoa nice i'm seeing it
nice good job
dosh guys don't spoil the ending for me does he win not yet
he said not yet locked in
jump I hate this fucking character in that fucking stupid
move I fucking hate it that's a good move yeah
dude it's my fault it's my fault might kill me here this
wall Yeah.
He's on his part and start command grabbing more.
He has no reason to duck after you're an ace vs because
you're not doing the the grab after.
You know what I mean?
So that's why he's not ducking.
You have to threaten the hunting bear stance grab.
But you got this.
You got this in the set.
If you get the grab and break the floor, it's back 2-2-1 for
your build.
Baming now.
I can just duck punish that, right?
You can duck it, yes.
Yeah, destroyed.
Shit.
Okay.
I'm syncing back up!
Nice.
I fucking jabbed, dude.
Oh, I'm so annoyed.
And I rolled back into him.
So close.
Nice.
Yeah, focus on your... Good, you get it!
Nice!
And to grab.
All right.
Got this.
What in the fucking...
There you go, bro.
Back 2-2-1.
it is back two to one and twice that's fine there you go you
need that yes that's gonna push your mix dude there you go
good nice that's two in a row final round fight oh that was
bad i gotta do the command grab
nice orbital
winnable very
i think i'm dead here i deadass radared too so i'm cg that's
close that's okay last round i mean like final final right
yeah i hate losing him so much i hate losing him josh good
news yourself and go to his room right now no the thing is i
would never i would never pop off like he popped off that's
the difference that's the that's the pepsi difference the
pepsi difference what's that god he's so miserable to lose
against oh my god my mind oh he's giving me props that's
really cool.
Was he giving me props when he went what?
It's okay.
That's your return redeem us.
Oh, this dude boxboxes.
Hello random, bro.
Yeah, you got a mission.
You haven't lost yet.
Come on, Matt.
You got it, man.
I don't know.
two points random you say that every time and you win every
time
whoa whoa whoa not that move bro
okay oh all right that's one
Round two.
Nice.
Yeah, that's crazy that that links.
Oh my god.
This stage is a good jack stage too.
So we got like good RNG.
Good rotation.
Yeah, definitely.
Round three.
Another rotation.
Oh, not fully.
Get rotated.
Did you pick this stage on purpose?
Oh, it's random.
Oh, shit.
Oh, we blocked this.
Oh, okay.
I forgot that Oscar's bullshit.
Oh, we blocked it.
I just saw him block it.
Shit.
Okay.
Actually.
Don't let us get swept.
Save us.
Hey, we still have Brawl Pro.
We still have him.
Don't rely on me.
I'm coming off an L.
There's no way you lose.
That's too much damage.
There should be more because...
There's a wall there!
No way.
Oh my god.
That's the criminal character.
Honestly, we need this.
We need this.
Oh my god.
That was the Joe Crush, bro.
Carry my ass.
I hate that trick song.
You have no idea.
Oh my god, what?
Oh.
Really?
Okay, never do that to Bogota.
Yeah.
The empty Spitfire Slayer.
Yeah, he came back.
from that oh fucking box box bro what the fuck is he doing
to you i don't know
oh my god oh he's locking it in that's all right that's all
right scott make it close see the delay oh my god yeah that
was a nice delay for his dog oh i can't king do this Shot of
nuts!
If only King has missile hands, he'll be perfect.
He really reacts to that.
That's crazy for a New York player.
Jesus.
Don't let him stand up!
Keep him on the floor!
How does he do it?
Yeah!
Fucking insane, dude.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go!
Just when you think he's at his lowest!
He came.
It's a miracle.
Slightly more correct.
I'm going to suddenly duck the grab because I can't take
grabs.
We didn't get swept guys.
Thank God.
Matt did it.
He saved us.
Always a miracle.
It's tough, man.
Yeah, man, there's a reason they're top top right now,
right?
They're right below us.
He was playing hella good too, but he like, he wasn't
optimizing, but he was like doing pretty good.
Yeah.
Not good enough.
It's too touching, man.
You guess wrong twice and you die.
Alright, we got our five points.
Yippee.
Yeah, good job, guys.
Oh.
Oh, Coach, you got this.
Redeem us, too.
The sequel.
I'll just play my best.
Good shit.
Nice.
dude oh my god take him to the wall perfect he's pressing
that's my fucking coach oh my head
oh oh
Oh, you can't really draw that because I can see his smash
That's scary.
Yeah
Come on
Yes, good shit Nice
Yes, sir Shit!
Nice!
End it with an alley kick!
For the fans?
For the people in the back?
I've been hitting him with a lot of mids, so I'm surprised
he's dunking.
It's because he sees King, he automatic ducks because of it.
That wall is close.
But they broke the wall.
Oh man, that sucks.
The tick move!
That's right, that's right.
You got this coach.
Yeah, you got the second set.
Nice.
Oh, good shit.
Oh, shit.
Oh, juicy.
Oh.
Muscle Buster.
That muscle Buster.
Close.
Brian, Freaky Brian.
Does that hurt?
Freaky Brian.
Does it hurt?
Freaky Brian?
It's hard to hit confirm when that down forward two
connects, but, and it hits.
these guys are smoothing man yeah he's like dancing oh it's
like those youtube videos are like perfect it's in the wall
oh jesus christ oh yeah i feel like he trained specifically
against kings oh mario yes i did not believe you got away
with that oh my god fade back fade back that's the mango
that's the mango the mango nice okay oh that's a lot that's
a lot of damage oh my god the jaguar run nothing this is too
scary i can't yeah yeah the sudden pause oh let's go break
his leg break it bro oh sharpshooter okay are you gonna
rotate him there's been so many people rotated today the
thing about freaky brian is he likes work oh big hop kick
nice
oh should be everything we dash oh let's try it let's try it
yeah it's a hard combo
Oh, I wish I hit that.
Oh, he
teched it.
Oh, King Titan Nash.
Nice.
Oh, the side wall adjustment.
Yeah, side wall adjustment is crazy here.
You're nuts.
Oh, my music fucking popping off.
rebel hangar final round playing oh wow
oh that's scary oh nice try he's clutching he's clutching
get a monk get a monk come on coach
nice what a dodge
What?
This is a bad spot to be in.
Not to take me.
Oh, that's...
No way!
Nice try.
Oh, nice try.
Oh my god.
He's very clutch.
Jesus.
I mean, like... Didn't get sweep.
Hey, I didn't get sweep.
Yeah, we needed that.
real bad oh that guy's really good mm-hmm that guy was
insane let's just hope that one of the teams beat them i
know tone really really really wants to win too like he
wanted me on his team and shit like he would be cool if
you're on my team oh my gosh we're definitely gonna see them
they're definitely getting one of the buys i feel oh yeah
yeah i think it's be between us and my case team we're just
trying to get the other one yeah i love that dude that is it
the turtle tweet oh my god that one was intense that felt
like the finals oh did you guys see the hard teams over hard
teams over the brawl pro chat the brawl pro hmm our oh yeah
in the in the hilarious
Yeah, that was kind of funny.
That was good.
Yeah, I'm losing kind of sucks.
Oh my god.
Losing sucks, dude.
That's why we're competitors.
Can't really.
That's why we lose now.
So we get motivated to win.
You have like so many, so much advice in the chat and you
just don't want to read any of it either, you know?
I know because you want to walk in and shit.
Like, oh, go Paul, go Paul.
It's like, fuck, I do not feel like this.
to this now now i know you're a streamer it's okay guys that
was the hardest team now like now now it's easy just don't
look at chat like i for the rest of my teammates i literally
i minimized the window i just play the game now it's easy i
got it it's for them that's respectable that you know what
that's true We got the hardest team out of the way The five
alley kicks in the dream right here What the fuck Shinru
isn't that like higher than Garu What is she doing my lobby
I'm a baby Bro I literally just fought Isam leave me alone
Leave me the fuck alone i literally had to fight what the
fuck okay i got confused too i'm sorry
oh my god please i had to fight esab get out of my lobby
okay oh god no no let's go team all right here you go God,
they really fucked the vibes up.
Not really, we got it.
The only thing is when winners lose, it's like, it's like
God, it's like God is turning down his head.
It doesn't make sense.
What?
How did she sidestep that?
I'm like fighting ESAM again!
It's gonna happen eventually.
There's only so long you can go without fucking losing,
dude.
I'm waiting for it.
Like, I don't think it's gonna be a big deal.
I don't care about it.
I think it's gonna happen against You guys saw that fucking
lag, dude.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I was gonna lag, dude.
I think it might be, like, a console issue or something.
Alright.
Like, that shit.
Oh, my God.
How did I fuck that up?
Of course it's me.
Of course, that's how I fuck it up.
Leave me alone!
Oh, my God.
Please!
I just thought I just thought if I ease them get out get out
Oh my god, get the fuck out of here
I almost had it.
I did not almost had it.
You know that
It's gonna be hard.
No, I don't want it to be hard I want to get it easily.
No epic.
I'm like three games from blue.
Did you promote?
I'm close.
I'm halfway to purple.
If I could get blue before Sunday, you know, that would feel
nice.
I feel like you just might as well just fucking strive for
it.
That's easy.
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
Look at that.
You're gonna learn how to play Tekken.
You better play Tekken.
Please!
Leave me alone, please!
I have to fight East, please!
Please leave me alone!
This is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
Bro, what the fuck are we doing here?
Alright.
Mental shattered!
No!
I was waiting for Flood to fight him!
No, what did he do to me?
What did he do to me?
Mental boom.
He boomed the mental.
How?
How is this possible?
He just went free in my head.
There we go.
Oh god.
Not a go.
There we go.
That should hit, right?
No!
How did I not hit?
There we go.
That should hit.
The ESAM curse.
Hey, bro.
Okay.
I lied to before, but I honestly haven't even died.
I know that obviously can literally let go of the rage art
midway, so it's not really a great sidewalk.
Oh my god.
But if you are gonna step it, is it left or right?
Bro, fuck off.
It's best to sidestep and then block.
So in case he does level two, you can still launch that.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, this is the other combo.
He delayed getting up.
That my thing didn't even hit.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
holy is he gonna duck no he didn't duck thank god oh thank
god he didn't duck either
no no no no no no no no no no oh no do i get up from that he
missed yes okay not intentional oh wait do i not get that
point did he unplug before oh Okay, I was like...
Yeah!
I did not intentionally save that.
But I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Oh, thank God.
How did you do the forbidden?
I did the forbidden!
I don't... I didn't...
No, I didn't!
It's called button mashing.
notification get ready for the next battle thank god for
button mashing uh did he actually play yeah i don't think
it's up yet oh yep bobby's up hey no i just got in the game
okay i'm i'll finish this rank match quick as in i'll lose
really quick round one fight all right come on yeah boom
boom boom yeah please let me win no please yes okay when did
this happen when did my neighbor get a drum set what you're
like oh this is gonna be fun moving forward oh no no no no
no no no no no no no no Oh, sorry.
Sorry, I had my mic on.
Oh, it's cool.
It's funny.
No.
Ah!
He caught.
Okay.
Let's join.
No.
I'll be hitting him one second.
Oh, my God.
He fucked up.
He fucked me up.
It's okay.
I didn't want to be red anyway.
I didn't.
I didn't want to be red anyway, guys.
Oh my god.
Wait, he predicted that?
How did he predict that?
My job is to be the same way.
Okay.
Let's go team.
I believe in all of you.
Oh my god.
I'm not playing that well.
Don't worry about it.
It's okay.
We lock in.
I don't walk in we lot we all walk in but then where he goes
Okay, don't worry about it man.
It's not even a song.
Oh I'm ranked right Okay, I'm going in here.
Let's go.
I'm ranked though.
Yeah.
Welcome.
Let's welcome go.
I mean goodbye sir I'm I'm locked in I got red
All right I fucking had it.
Alright.
I had a crab.
It's fine if I lose or win.
I have red rings.
Honestly, like me too, I feel like I'm playing like weird.
So it's not even split.
Alright guys, for once in my life I'll hide the passcode.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna do it guys.
Joki, she's not even ranked that much higher than you to be
honest.
Very winnable.
Yeah, but I feel like she actually knows what she's doing
because she played the this game much longer.
I feel like she knows more than seven moves.
Alright, guys.
You can't blame me if somebody joins this lobby.
I actually hit the code.
It's not me this time.
Oh, you did?
I'm not putting in that much effort.
I'll say it.
I gave up.
SageM has a toupee.
The whole world's upside down.
What are these rumors slime it's not a rumor everyone in the
fgc knows this knows what that sayjam has a toupee really
yeah it's real he's like hitman bald oh my god why does he
use his hair so much i know why does he care if you're bald
you're smarter because you mulled so much that's what i'm
saying extra brain space man his chat was probably making
fun of him for being bald so he went and got to pay it's
good didn't you rub it for good luck what do you think
exactly he'd be crazy at fighting games bro he he's wearing
a to pay because he's hiding his power that's why he's not a
pro player that's that's the broccoli weights yeah he can't
be a pro he's not he doesn't commit
oh man no wonder isam is so good oh my god no wonder he's so
good because he's bald it's true yeah isam does get the
weird bald buff it's also why i'm the best in the world at
this
what are you what are you waiting for y'all can go ahead and
start okay fight me in sks sks oh we were waiting for Oh, he
woke up.
Look, he woke up.
I was like, who are we waiting for?
Finally!
I can show the screen.
Let's go.
You can't yell at me, guys.
If somebody joins the lobby.
Okay, but I hate playing as Rina, though.
She's so fast.
She's so fucking fast.
I'm too bulky.
Just two reds duking it out.
That's what you love to see.
Yeah.
Honest red gaming.
This is this is true.
I proof forced this right.
This is what I'm here for.
Wait, what was her weak?
I don't remember what her weakness was.
Coach, you didn't tell me.
Coach, what do I do?
Run your shit.
Can we not talk about SK?
No, we didn't.
We didn't.
We never did.
Run your shit.
Let's go.
What do I do, coach?
That's your shit.
Wait, who's that?
Just do that.
Do what?
That!
That?
You're playing it right now!
This?
Yump and you're doing.
Yump.
It just happened.
You just did all of it.
I did that.
Oh my god, I did that.
Did you see that, coach?
She took though.
Yeah.
Okay, I think she knows now.
She knows now.
i feel like time to use that mid yep oh wait the square yeah
when you're in the sprint it's okay it's time oh no way
we're not pressing down one time what do you mean i told you
it's time no one ever expects it wait she don't she she
actually oh she's mixing it up yeah she's mixing it up wow
smart player there's no way no what is this mental block i
don't know they never an aura like there's no way it's weird
because they get it and then they lose it yeah i don't
understand either i don't understand why they don't okay
legendary and the slime and i would need to learn take a
book out of fucking Doki's face.
With that shit.
All right.
Finish it.
She dodged.
Nice try.
Fight.
Remember, you can do that running knee if...
Okay.
I was trying to, but then like...
Oh my god.
I tried to, but like I pressed the...
I pressed square.
Okay.
Yes!
Oh god.
Right?
Oh, no!
I couldn't!
Oh.
Nice rage art?
I think we did this.
No!
She got it!
Oh, it's too strong.
Oh.
Oh, the misery.
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
I never...
I hate that move, though, in rank.
Oh, what?
Okay.
Hey.
Nice.
Okay.
Big.
Nice mix up.
Okay.
I got it.
Let's go.
I did it.
Oh, that was good.
That was good job.
That was close.
Good.
25 hours Jokey versus 100 hour Rana.
Oh, SK is definitely at 125 now.
You're five times.
Baby versus Bob.
Yeah, Hydrogen Bob.
Yeah.
Did your maps get the bound?
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Nice.
You said you're five times better.
You don't want to see Doki Bird at 125 hours.
Yeah, you don't want to see 100.
I don't think I have the hours for that either, to be fair.
Suplex.
Okay.
No way.
I just...
Nope.
I like how you didn't hop kick either.
Yeah, that was good.
Oh my god, dude.
Guys, I feel like they're gonna learn this by the finals,
though.
They're looking like a pretty good move, bro.
I mean, I'm just saying, like, that was pretty good.
Oh my god.
Dude, she's fucking swagging.
This is crazy.
What?
It's only correct decision.
What the fuck?
How did she keep getting away with this?
Play Devil May Cry.
How did she keep getting away?
Oh, big dog.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
She like fucking mixes it up, so it's hard.
Nice.
Oh, no.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, she hits it.
Oh, dog.
That's fine, that's fine.
Yeah, she had to use lightning herself to kill you just to
be clear.
Hey, we start out with that.
No, fuck.
Round start, alley kick.
You're about to get King's worst low nerfed.
Just because of what I do.
That show just through Harada.
Harada's watching, I guarantee you right now.
Oh my god.
Do you think that was intentional for her?
That shit was like a movie.
Yeah, holy shit.
Okay, when you pop heat, hold on to your heat smash.
Don't pop it right away because she's blocking it.
Oh, okay.
Just hold on to it a little bit.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I think she actually is learning.
Yeah, that was a good adaptation.
We're still live, still live.
Oh, my gosh.
Boom.
All right, that's big.
Do I do square or grab?
You run up, grab.
Matt, let's get it.
Big Reef.
Wait till she gets up, though.
Wait till she gets up.
Because sometimes they like on the...
Stay on the ground.
There you go, there you go.
I pop heat.
Easy, easy.
Pop heat when she gets up.
I heat smash and go mid.
Square, square.
No!
Matt, bad read, Matt!
Oh, nice try, nice try.
Bad read!
A plan is worse, is better than no plan at all.
It's Matt's fault.
Yeah, you blew it.
You blew it for us.
I can only be read so many times.
I'm sorry.
The wrong read.
Okay, do that running.
and grab a lot she has not taken a single one and then she's
gonna and it's gonna be a bad read again oh my god what the
fuck oh my god she mad she's mad now the bounce okay she's
fucking mad now she's fucking mad oh my god she's so mad i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry She's gonna block this.
There's no way.
Alright, true, true, true, true.
We sent it all there.
Okay.
I like the idea.
We're playing Tekken.
This is some Tekken.
We're playing Tekken, yeah, right here.
Right now.
This is Tekken.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah, this is definitely Tekken.
nice i love your patience it's so good yeah oh i think i
need to be more patient guys
that's huge no what oh no i thought i thought you pressed
it's okay still alive no she actually blocked it it's okay
and in the end i got that one set not over that's true
that's true
that I don't know but yeah that looked fucking freaky though
freaky techniques yeah that's a freaky technique though not
gonna lie is real in a tier yeah okay that's a freaky
fucking technique oh fuck I should have grabbed guys it's
okay I got us that five points though wait we get points per
per game do we get per say in the beginning no oh we don't
this time No!
No, I should have used more alley kicks.
I know, I blame Matt.
Alley kicks probably would have made her knees explode.
She would have been a smoking pair of shoes in the
Colosseum.
So true.
What's the code for this lobby?
It doesn't let me spectate, so I restart it.
How do I say it to you without leaking?
It's 8-9-2-1.
Oh, I guess it doesn't matter, yeah.
We did this fucking yesterday, I'm so stupid.
Oh god.
It's right there.
Who's next?
The fire just wants to play everyone.
He will not plus R2.
Let's go, Kony.
I should have Ali kicked more.
Let's go, goat.
Let's go, goat!
Come out, Kony.
Bring it back.
Redeem me.
Oh, I got a good stage.
Ooh.
It's the comet, asteroid, whatever it is.
Floor blast on the third round, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, she's always going to start off with that side step.
Round one.
Shoulder.
I hate fighting her and me.
Yeah, she can be an
enemy.
Oh.
Got it.
Island Kony.
Come out, Kony!
The Bahamas.
Nice!
Round two.
The coach didn't teach her that.
They will by the tournament time.
Yep.
Yeah, definitely.
Do you think they're using you?
You're so cute right now.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm just gonna abuse that.
Oh my god.
Your points.
That's just our layer one, so that's okay.
I tried to go the muscle buster.
Yeah, I would have exploded the wall.
Nice.
That's what I'm trying to land here.
I don't want to try to force it too much though.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, she broke it.
Wow.
Got it.
It's a resting button.
That was insane.
Yeah.
We're in your regular combo now.
Sorry.
Oh no!
I got it.
If she's smart, she'll switch the changes.
Yeah.
Because you can, but...
I mean, I didn't earlier.
I don't think it...
Has anyone actually swapped a stage?
think so yeah i think we're just autopiling on this i would
i would just be like get rematch go again i lose i win all
right all right matt but you didn't you never lost you don't
need a saw stages you don't lose yeah
nice oh got it let's go back three baby down back three
she's just really scared Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh.
So I can just control pace.
Oh my goodness.
I'm going to do that to SK in the finals.
Yup.
Oh, she doesn't take try and swing.
Oh.
God, bro.
You're nice.
If she's struggling to sprint to me now, the alley kicks.
Like she's scrambling to find an opening.
So if I just swing every time, it's like, I don't know.
I think her brain scrambled.
Yeah.
It's annoying.
This matchup's very annoying, so I get it.
Or not the matchup, but I guess King.
Yeah, King was annoying.
She's breaking every map.
Yeah, she's breaking.
A counter hit throws, too.
Is she matching or is she actually knowing the tech?
Well, she's broken both twos and threes.
Or twos and ones, so.
And this might end up.
Two and one plus two.
Yeah, so much.
She's got.
Nice job.
All right.
Okay, let's just assume it won't be that fee in finals, but
I appreciate the points lightweight baby.
Yeah, fee has to teach her that like that should not hit
like just lay down, you know All right, let me read my fang
notes fang way.
All right, you got it really hard good I believe in you Oh,
wait, was it this guy?
I think it was this guy, right?
Or am I thinking of ray?
It's one of the things fair light is the fang who is pretty
hard okay we talked about it and remember uh slime he's
gonna lay down in a lot of okie situations when you like to
do the running one plus two so that's a forward forward two
yep and don't start the round with the buttons he's always
waiting for you okay maybe you can start with like a down
back two maybe if you really want something and back one
plus two hunting bears stands one plus two will probably get
this guy look at the cause how do i get in there uh who is
unban me brawl who the fuck is that how are they getting
anything bad i mean that's so cringe we're doing chat
unbending i want you to know that you will you will never be
valued for from the people that you watch every day ever
remember like well we know the leaks not coming from us for
sure it's coming from inside the brawl pro chat yeah it's
like what it's our it's actually our alt accounts by the way
it's one of us
i like at least he's sitting on the sidelines like yeah he's
not holding the lobby hostage he's he's making a statement
all right let's do it baby oh that's a new costume is that
the punishing round one oh my god he has a gun maybe it's
jason there's that snake edge
wow this guy's a nerd
gotta stop doing that so i'm gonna clean up
doing that nice job All right, time to mix it.
Time to mix it.
I waited.
Deal.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Where did your HP go?
How did two grab?
That's a one or two.
You could have killed him if you did the wall combo.
Yeah.
Fight.
Okay, we got this.
Oh my god.
There it is.
I'll get him.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh, Jake left didn't work.
That's okay.
Good shit.
Nice!
Yeah!
Oh, Jake left didn't work.
Round four.
Fight.
Ooh!
No.
I thought he'd do a low, he just kept doing the running one.
Can I step that?
If I know what's coming?
Not if, yeah, but if you, if he hits you with it and it
knocks you down and then you tag, then probably not.
He just shouldn't do that pose.
When he's T-O-ing, I mean, if you can react to it, you block
that, you can twin piston it.
T-O is really bad, that shoulder.
Round one,
fight.
Oh my god.
We have to threaten the hunting bear, grab.
I'm really bad, man.
I can't fucking...
All right.
Let's play the game.
He's definitely overwhelming for sure.
That was sick.
You can also that roll guard break remember.
No way.
I would definitely rage guard him after he does something
like that.
Like a heat burst.
Yeah.
You have it.
He's mashing every time.
Oops.
Okay.
Yeah, he's breaking one plus two every time.
Oh, the punish!
Oh my god!
Go slam!
He's flying.
Not yet.
Oh, nice.
Yeah!
Oh, cool, man.
Good dive.
Hmm, how does that work?
Tio!
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Always grabbing from Oku when he gets get up.
Oh wow.
I didn't know he could do another fucking kick.
What a being miserable fucking character.
He's a strong player.
played last night he was taking he's good not sets but he
was taking rounds off of me like why would you play the
character that does that pose i was thinking that makes you
think which makes you think like what are you really about
man yeah that man i was gonna say anything but if you're
gonna say it that's all are
they updating the points live or probably not right probably
not yeah gotcha here we go laggy as fuck eddie zafina i'm
gonna say it like i'll definitely try but i like this guy
he's playing on a microwave man i don't know it's okay if
you're lagging he's lagging this is like literally like the
most ranked tech and match i've ever experienced like one
bar eddie jack oh no jack he said fuck your character Oh, I
saw him in the general last night.
He said this was gonna be a jack-off.
Oh my god
That's what he said chat.
Is this real?
Oh my god the Jack mirror Did he give up?
No, he's not the undertaker bro.
Oh That is the other father Gascoigne Bloodborne, whatever
his name is
god that's fucking right a jack off okay don't do that
understood gone out of jacking off like he's jacking it he's
jacking it wait what wait what do you guys mean by that what
is when you yeah yeah you know in the race of jacks What
were you thinking about?
Yup.
Watch the raid.
Jack him harder!
Oh, keep moving.
No, it's true.
He's got a jack as hard as he can.
You can't look him in the eyes.
Somebody's gonna start a fire.
You gotta look him in the eyes!
Oh, we're distracting him.
We should stop.
Round three.
Maybe.
Oh, yeah, counter hit, blue spark, everything.
Oh, don't don't.
Yeah.
Oh, that was sick.
That's okay.
That was sick.
That was a lot.
Oh.
Fight.
Damn, the double jacks, man.
no way oh nice counter hit dude shit you're back on eddie
good shit
i'm throwing a set away thank you let me throw on the set
away all right yeah leave the lobby all right some calling
the jack hammy don't don't do that i know I know like you
got a lot of tech and experience under your years and shit,
but in a new game just play Eddie.
I want to play What the fuck?
I don't know why you picked Jack on me man.
Well, remember when we were gonna bot review him?
He did play Jack, yeah.
Why do I- he's got a very legacy Jack, not a single Gamma
Hal.
Yeah, he did- he didn't do- Oh my god, I hate this guy.
All right, brawl pro, I actually need your help.
Oh, Zahina.
remember that power crush oh thank you mystical so you
pressure him you can yeah okay
why do they play such freaky characters i've not seen the
team she's so freaky watch watch she'll get on the ground
it's a freak festival isn't the one where she climbs on like
a spotty yeah yeah yeah i just like i hate her Okay.
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh my God.
Good shit.
What a genius.
Nice.
Ooh.
Send them to space, check.
You're going into orbit.
Round two.
Fight.
That's not fair.
That's your point.
Spamming is banned.
Somebody should tell him.
No, no, no.
Allie kicks have been paying us.
We need the alley kicks.
I almost BSK on alley kicks alone.
The fact that it worked, like, not once, but three times in
a row was what surprised me.
What is she doing?
If you stepped on her head, she would die.
is she doing that that is not an advantageous position like
a watermelon she weighs like a hundred and ten pounds all
right I'm not afraid of Zaf we get one punch let's go 58
defense of my go 58 defense 58 that's two right I don't
fight again well there's one more one more yeah you won two
yeah sorry so I'm yes yeah okay okay all right dude if i
lose a third koja match i need a therapy session okay i will
give you the biggest hug at evo we're gonna be there anyway
don't worry about it it's all right let's all get dinner
let's go to evo i want to i was trying to i was trying to
figure out like a good dinner spot so i was gonna hit you
guys up to be like hey you want to tell me this year yeah
i'm down dude let's get it's in evo every year dokey are you
gonna go or not i don't super is i think he's gonna go too
so we should invite him to dinner yeah you got this my goat
my uncle my dad my everything come on coach this is it gotta
bring it home last story i'll study up for the turning like
on uh in two days from now i see my mistakes like they'll
duck like i grab and then i'll lose like half my life and
then the oaky situation me and then it's rough out here man
these guys are good how did he improve so fast i don't
understand steve this time you're supposed to stop all right
i'm gonna close my chat i like my chat we'll be your chat
we'll be your chat don't worry that's that bayonetta on
steve that's steven that's steven bayonetta and gender bend
Oh,
it's Kojima.
Oh, maybe.
Kojima doesn't wear pajama bottoms.
No.
Kojima on break.
Good shit.
I like the little push.
Nice.
That's what the fuck I'm talking about, baby.
Oh, yeah.
I'm not sure.
Round three.
Damn.
Oh.
freaky steve i'll say it it's just us against the freaky
army that's it every team just studied our gameplay only
nice nice okay love that punch him in the nut Oh!
Good shit!
Nice!
It's stacking.
I love how it's like chicken, playing chicken right now.
Let's go!
Good shit!
Alley kick, baby!
Hell yeah!
Good ass move!
We get distributions from big alley kick.
Yeah!
The alley kick clutch.
Oh That's a wall Steven take him to that wall Bro
is counting
Nice how does it fucking We need this What the low parry?
Oh, dude The fuck does that move?
Let's go That move hit the end out.
It would hurt.
Blood is a boxer.
They don't do that shit in his ring.
Round one.
You might go, bro.
Attack in.
Go, baby.
I don't even know what this move is.
What the fuck?
It may be one of these.
Oh, it's like a chiropractor.
Are you sure to make a little adjustment?
You guys.
Nice.
This guy's not playing around anymore.
Can you keep saying that?
Oh, what?
It was a clinch.
Big hug.
It doesn't matter.
Let's give me some three heads in chat.
Up out!
Fun!
Fire!
Big B!
Sausage!
Nice!
Oh my god.
I see.
Laugh!
No, be close.
Simple as.
Oh no way.
That was so weird.
That's so weird.
Oh good.
That was so weird.
Look ahead.
Coach, get up, coach.
Wow, that was so sick.
Oh my god.
That was nice.
Okay, that was good for him.
Oh, nice!
I'm so funny that his that's his optimal look very
comfortable.
Nice!
He's so clean with the flow.
He's doing it.
Oh.
Buddy.
Okay.
One more.
That's for your life.
Good shit.
Bro, bro.
Let's go.
I love you, Unk.
Let's get this done.
Oh, look at all these blocks.
Nice!
What's his ass?
Oh wow.
Oh.
Take him to a wall, yes!
Real freaky hours.
We're in the basement now.
It's wall time.
What if we get the wall?
What if we get the wall, bitch?
Yes!
Call him wall pro.
Oh.
He blocked that.
Yeah, he has to rest a little.
He's got no clutch bone, no clutch bone.
What the fuck did he just do?
Oh, I pressed.
No!
Nice try, nice try, nice try.
Yeah.
That was nice.
That was a good rage art.
Yeah.
That was good.
That was a really good rage art.
Shit.
All right.
Well, that was a good fight though.
That was good.
Yeah.
Oh!
Masha was insane.
Mm-hmm.
Download.
He's only 26 Daniels.
You're 100 Daniels.
Come on, you win this, you'll be 120 Daniels.
Mm-hmm.
You steal his Daniels.
Yeah.
Those Daniels need a new home.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
Nice break That was unfortunate Round two Fight Oh Damn
Nice Oh Shit
Oh my god, you're a player.
Oh my god, those ducks!
Let's go.
It's like he actually knows how to play Tekken.
Fight.
Nice.
Oh my god, that camera.
Oh, Dauper!
It's his alley kick.
His brain is scrambled.
The alley kick!
No one knows what to do!
His brain is scrambled.
Do it again!
Let's fucking go!
I think he scrambled, bro.
He saw what I did to SK and he got worried.
His brain is hot right now.
Oh, whoa, that was a good sidestep.
Nice.
Oh!
Hmm.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
A bomb.
Let's go.
Oh, they're doing nothing to win that.
I'm going to attack him last.
There it is.
I agree.
Let's go, coach.
Yes.
Take the win.
Good shit, dude.
Oh, not even close.
Not even close.
It's because he used to play melee.
Yeah, sure.
Hit the shot.
he's got he's got that actual unbreakable monkey his name is
brawl pro to be clear guys we claim him we gotta
congratulate him on his first win today his first win yeah
thank you thank you oh hey welcome to the club join the club
join the winners club nice job hey we kind of did well yeah
we took you we were cooking yeah we take this we take this
all the record especially you know five points per that's
big yeah yeah yeah yeah all right yeah we're looking good so
far on the because we did four one uh let me see four one
one four but then three two so we're in a good spot i think
also we got the hardest team out of the way so yeah yeah
yeah don't say that didn't what if like you're gonna carve
us bro the team for you for me that's just like All teams
are the same.
I got all demons every single day of my life.
I'm fighting them.
I'm falling asleep.
And you beat them all.
You haven't lost yet, Jack.
I will be losing.
You've literally been saying that for two slams.
It's his strat.
It's like his reverse jinx.
It's actually impossible for me to lose because if I lose,
then I'll say, yeah, I told you guys I would lose.
But if I don't, then I look like a fucking god.
You let that thing get me last this.
yeah I'll be losing soon I'm sure don't say that don't say
that because what if that happens in the finals we got scara
and Amaz you guys saw how they were playing armor hop kick
armor jigsab every defensive option ever like I got to make
a read on what the fuck they're gonna do like you guys read
not me my brain run away playing overwatch and pecking and
then yeah do we have a while till the next one yeah do we
have a while uh not sure i'm gonna go get some water and uh
use a bathroom a little refresher all right time to practice
checking oh my
god i'm playing as a tenru now i'm too high rank I don't
belong here.
Yeah.
Guys, I don't belong in this Elo.
I literally lucked out on this Elo.
I brute forced my way into this Elo.
Like, literally, I have not been playing that much Tekken.
I'm pretty... I don't think I belong here.
Oh no.
Please.
Leave me alone.
I don't even know how to juggle.
That's how I don't belong here.
I don't even know how to juggle people.
Yay!
Whoops, that was an accident.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Here you go.
Curried by alley kicks.
Bro, some people spend their entire lives fucking grinding
to this elo.
I don't know how I get here.
That's the saddest part.
Some people spent their entire lives getting here.
Oh, I just existed.
I at least kicked my way to victory.
I think, like, including the games now, I think I have 30
hours on Tekken.
30 hours on Tekken for a red rank.
It just works!
Just don't use it.
told you i don't i don't belong here the moment i learned uh
for like a fifth and sixth move i i went up to rings like
yesterday i was at i think dominator i think yesterday i was
at dominator i think i started at dominator or something
right and then in like and then when i learned the fifth and
I went up to red.
So, like, every move unlocks a rink.
She keeps getting away.
I don't know how.
I don't know how I keep doing it.
It's actually crazy.
Like, I literally don't know what I'm doing.
Like, I should not be getting away with this.
Is this the same guy?
Is it?
I'm sorry, bro.
Bro, get your back natural instinct bro I'd be mad like no
I'd understand oh shit bro I think he's angry that I tried
to one and done him yeah he's definitely guys I think he's
angry I I'm pretty sure he's angry
I'd be angry too, not gonna lie.
Yay!
Boop!
Oh, oh, he actually defended that.
Oh!
Please!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Please!
I'm sorry.
Wait, he actually blocked those.
You know, that's when you know he's like an actual gamer.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He's sidestepped.
He actually knows what he's doing.
I literally got here as a fluke.
He got his Elo back.
He figured me out.
Lobby time.
Okay.
This is why I won and done people.
Because like they figure it out by the second game.
Alright, here I'll go.
Where's the lobby at?
There it is.
I'll be in in one second.
I'm joining, I'm joining.
Alright guys, I'm gonna hide the passcode.
So it's not my fault.
all right guys it's 2250
all right here i am guys i think this guy learned though the
hard hard what's his name again the logan rdj guy i'm pretty
sure he learned how to counter me okay back okay back i'm
pretty sure i abused so we are hiding the uh the thingamajig
so desired to do so.
Uncle, you may.
They're asking if we're ready, but none of you guys are in
here.
Yeah, they're asking if you're ready, but if we're ready,
but none of you are here in here.
I'm about to join.
Literally, the only thing I see is slime.
Slime is the only person here with me.
I'm a good egg.
We're going to start without Kony, I guess.
I'm coming in.
i'm coming in i'm coming in sorry i'm finishing my match too
sorry
after this i need to use the bathroom gotta hurry
oh my god they they kicked out logan
all right i'm in yippee all right we got this this is your
time this is it it wait he doesn't you're actually this
you're actually the same rank at this as this guy yeah why
didn't this guy rank up not not have a grind set no grind
set like you what this guy started like a week earlier than
me and i caught up in three days
what's that possible
here i go it's okay if i lose it's okay it's all about the
experience and i know my teammates got me got you dog
waiting for opponent what do you have to pick ready for the
next battle probably the stage waiting for that the good
random maybe he was timing it you can time it oh my god it's
one punch man oh he's serious he's actually serious okay
how's that coach staying on oh my god he's so he's actually
serious now yeah that's true yeah it doesn't make sense and
it's not one pick it's a great many he already it up how did
he oh my god i get it i get it so good yay yay that roar
with the game was synced up i want you to know that someone
clipped up please oh my god wait i Three.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay.
I should have done more alley kicks.
It's only hop kick on five.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Yeah, that's true.
Grab or something after.
Oh, he ducks now.
I think like after what I did to him, he's got, he like
learned.
What a darn.
What a shame, Doug.
Yes.
Oh, cool.
Who is this?
This shit.
Nice.
Nice!
Oh, good legend.
Oh, you're a legend.
Good shit!
Unbelievably nuts.
Oh shit.
He doesn't do that thing that abused him last time, you
know?
Yeah, that string.
Yeah, he doesn't do that anymore.
Because I think he got tilted with that.
Wait, what?
It didn't hit?
Oh, the timing was crazy.
It worked!
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay.
He was ready for that.
Yeah.
Fight!
Oh, that's not that one.
Oh, that was an accident.
Oh, no, he got me.
What?
How does he do that?
This is a good scrap.
Now it was square.
Oh, what the?
Oh, no.
Nice try.
Good try.
He figured me out.
he downloaded me from yesterday or two days ago we download
back okay what do i do now we beat his ass what do i do when
he knocks you down just when he knocks you down just get up
just hold back and get up instead of uh getting up with a
bunch of like uh one two three four buttons just just get up
with back and just hold back if he knocks you down oh oh my
god he definitely against the king he did not like that yeah
he definitely played against a lot of kings good heavens you
don't have to get up either you can stay grounded if you
want oh i should should i yeah yeah against this guy yeah i
feel like i should yeah this guy oh
Oh my gosh.
Good stuff.
Oh, what the fuck?
How didn't that work?
How come that doesn't work?
He ducked it.
He actually ducks?
Yeah.
He's mixing it up.
So you run into him and do the knee to mix up.
Remember that running knee.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
All right.
Well, it worked.
Yay!
Oh, no.
What a break.
Yep.
Oh.
Okay.
Cooked.
Yay.
That's counter hit.
Oh my god.
Oh, what?
Oh, he sidestepped.
Focus, focus.
Oh, he sidestepped me.
Go live.
Did I hit those?
Let's fucking go.
Nice job.
Good job.
Oh my god.
I hit it.
Oh.
Good shit.
I hit those!
Oh, yes!
Oh, I should...
I need to do the square.
Yeah, the square.
Because he's a square.
That's right.
Boom!
Oh, he ducks it now!
He blocks it!
You told me nobody blocks this, you liar!
I thought I'm so good Nice try Is that right?
He actually learned from me That's just raw adaptation And a
skull necklace That's true, that's true He was one punch man
How the fuck do I kill that guy?
I don't think we can Yeah Yeah Like me used to bat doom You
got this Kony Do what I couldn't do Wait Doki You have to
hit the rage I got you I got you Thank you.
That was fun.
Get ready for the next battle.
Let's get it, brother.
I hate this stage.
It's for you.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh, that's okay.
Lots of grabs.
Do again.
Okay.
Lots of grabs.
I got it.
Oh.
Wow.
Big counter hit.
What the hell?
Nice.
Good weight.
Oh, that goes back so far.
You forward to one that if you block that.
Okay.
Damn, they all train against Kings.
Got it.
Ooh, that was...
Nice!
Wow, what a swing.
Nice jump.
Start off with Kankans.
My guess is she's starting with Kankans because her coach
told her to go the low on Power Crush.
Do you have them pulled out?
No, just a guess.
Okay, okay.
that'd be a crazy intelligence yeah oh my god hit her out of
that that's crazy angle slam wait i thought she was dead
yeah i didn't press anything yeah it's for you after angle
slam she has hadukin as well so be careful no she lost her
heat though she doesn't have heat oh i'm looking at the
other fucking guy sorry you're looking at her teammate Oh my
god, I punched.
All right.
Got it.
Nice.
Jab, jab.
Apparently so much chat said, like, this team actually
exclusively trained against kings.
That makes sense.
And where is it getting them?
Like, let's do it real here.
Oh, how many?
Oh, I know.
I didn't think it was out of time.
Doki Bird special.
They never trained against this, though.
Oh, almost.
Good job.
Nice win punish.
What the fuck?
Allie kick is free there.
Allie kick.
Oh, fuck.
You're right.
Nice.
Let's go.
Yeah.
They might have beat my king, but they haven't beat Koni's
king.
Coach Koni.
You can't download him.
He's can-canning.
Here it is.
Oh, she's scrambling at a block.
Our beautiful, beautiful patient man.
Not a good reaction time.
No, no.
What am I just talking about, dude?
I know where it's channeled it.
I remember.
That was unreal, dude.
That's okay.
Allie cake, fuck it.
oh nice she's scrambling she's nervous he's lost it just uh
snowballer he looked at the wrong king the trained against
oh my yes grab i was gonna say because her coach definitely
told her to grab first so i mean expecting grab on run up
but i'm trying too hard because i feel like she's back there
and if you're trying to chase him yeah you can forward to
one that if right right the chase you're right backlifting
yes you have okay shiny wizard now yes no no all good all
good nice
good boom wall oh take her to that wall guaranteed wall five
six seven how long can you go do it again all right just
pressure bro it's just pressure bro you should have kept
going until she stopped just keep alley kicking 100 alley
kick and plus one alley do it again you could have done it
nice job nice job all right freaky gin time i taught him
that i taught him the alley kick
It's your turn.
Get me in there.
Well, Kony also has to...
Yeah, there it is.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh man.
Can you imagine if this was a Street Fighter slam and like
the team had like three Zangiefs?
Yeah, right.
That team would lose badly.
Yeah, exactly.
Is that like the king equivalent?
No, he's a grappler.
He's a grappler in Street Fighter.
Actually, I don't know.
I feel like low-level zanky if especially on modern like a
guile is not gonna know what to do Like a first-week guile,
you know what I mean Same stages last time tell them to get
a street fighter three hondas would fuck yeah hondas a
better equipped hondas would fuck people up You know in a
street fighter sling that character is Annoying if you're
new Good shit Make a presence nice Download him
I mean, do that, but this works.
No, it doesn't.
Close, though.
I didn't think I'd launch on that.
Yeah, the but would have been guaranteed that.
Oh, nice.
Look at the chip.
Jesus.
Oh, geez.
Can't get out of pressure.
We talked about that.
Okay.
Wow.
He got a broken.
He knew it.
Nice.
He got up wrong.
Oh, God.
That was a fun test then.
Oh.
Smack him.
Okay.
That was good punished by that guy.
Nice job.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's the main character.
He has the main character buff.
That's not fair.
Why does this fucking launch?
What is this shit?
That's how the map is going.
I'm trying to do it.
He's doing this 2-1-4 and it's like a high mid-mid.
It's like two punches and a kick.
He keeps counter hitting you.
Can I kick left it?
No.
If he delays it, yeah.
But he's not delaying it.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh.
that yeah that
oh i'm bad i'm bad sorry you'll get used to it
he plays like a bot like a fucking ai need to play this is
what i said remember two days ago i was like he just plays
like the most regular tech you've ever seen yeah so like he
he takes it really slow right yeah he's not doing a lot
Yeah.
Oh, that's what we're talking about, baby!
Oh, guaranteed.
That's crazy.
It's all good.
You got a big lead.
Oh my god, what a timing.
Why?
Dude.
I hate this fucking Pokemon.
I remember you have a heat.
Just burst.
It's like the end of the round.
Yeah.
How does that fucking happen, dude?
If I'm holding back, I don't think I'm gonna do it.
Come on, buddy.
Alright, good start.
4.42.
I'm looking at these.
I know it's a duck here.
God, what a bot.
Also a nice person in real life.
I fucking hope so.
I think so.
Sean Clare, Sean Clare, Sean Clare.
Jen is strong.
Jen is power.
No, no.
I'm just not blocking.
I'm just fucking terrible.
He gave you a lot of cookies.
He whiffed a few times.
It's okay, Matt.
Matt takes it home for us.
Okay.
I'm actually losing this one.
I'm not even kidding.
Let's go.
No, no, no.
This is the most random fucking place I've ever met.
Jesus.
A religion started because of him.
the strongest bot on the planet save me jack jesus you're
the equivalent of an alley kick he says he'll lose every
time he is so modest praise him praise him start a call
bestow upon the list of your many blessings oh it's a
miracle he keeps saying he's gonna lose and he keeps it's
miracles oh my god yeah that's what it is he's gonna walk on
water next Oh shit, it's Alyssa.
What the fuck?
I'm speed- oh my god, Doom.
Oh, interesting.
What the fuck?
Let's get it.
Me win, Shane.
Oh my
god.
It's cool, it's cool.
It's still not a lead.
Fuck.
Whoa.
How do I turn the input and history on?
L2?
Thanks.
Yeah!
What the fuck happened in my armor?
You pressed, you have to hold it?
Fuck.
Nah, I mean, I should have canceled little bubble.
I didn't come out.
It's alright.
Go.
It's okay.
Just one set.
A lot of these strings that have these highs in them that if
you knew about them, you could like her 1-1 or 10 frame
punish is a high high.
Also, there's two hits that go into chainsaws.
She only, well, I mean, I can't explain it now, but just
know there are gaps.
Good block.
Oh, Oh my god, I hate this guy.
Wow, again!
Yeah, let's bait out the hop kick then.
Boom.
Nice.
What is that move?
I know, fuck Alyssa.
I hate playing against Jade.
Okay.
Round 2.
Let's get it.
Nice.
Big!
Big hit.
Take her to the moon!
Get her out of this game!
Yes!
That string, that's the highest of chainsaw.
Okay, okay, okay.
I literally just don't know the strings.
Nice!
Last hit!
On the board!
Not close at all.
Oh, what the fuck, man?
What the fuck this character?
What?
I mean, that's green, but even- Ah, yeah, we just said-
Okay.
Even this, this is gonna scale too, because Alyssa's always
in the air.
Wait, really?
That's crazy.
That's so dumb.
Nice!
Oh, nice!
Also in the air.
What the fuck?
Uh-oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, what happened?
I tried to blast off!
The Patriot fist.
Okay, yeah, if I'm not doing this, then I'm not doing well.
Oh, it's over for me, Boros.
No.
I feel it.
We turn this around.
Oh, I'm dead, bro.
Yeah, yeah.
Good, good.
Try, man.
I'm getting good.
No, let's try.
You know what?
We got the loss out of the way.
We got it out of the way.
Look, this team hard trained against us, so it makes sense,
you know?
it although the streak is over that gives us a chance to
start a new streak that's right a better there it is there
it is it was even longer yeah and then look at this shit
another fucking elissa it's gonna go all the way to evo
makes you think i can't believe it they went anti-team bp i
mean they did that last time too after we won the uh the
round That's so fucked up.
That's true, Chet.
Jack Jesus fell on Friday, he will rise on Sunday.
Oh, true!
It is the Lord's Day.
He died for our sins, guys.
Yeah, 2-Round Robin's probably hurt us more.
Because this happened to us last time, but...
Round 1.
Fight.
Good shit.
Ooh.
He is so fast.
Coach, you need to train us for the scene.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Yes, sir.
Hell yeah.
Come on, coach.
You're better.
Oh, we busted.
What am I doing?
We're having lots of fun.
Exactly.
Oh, look at her life.
There's a wall.
Oh, oh my god.
Did we send another?
Oh my god.
Did it again.
Oh, shoot.
Boom.
Let's go, baby.
A
bench match.
Oh my god.
All those blocks.
One day my coach would teach me how to block.
my one weakness oh wow what a fucking let's go it takes me
the elissa matchup what the fuck yeah we'll work on the
elissa matchup like tonight uncle the baptist you know i
think it's because like bravo didn't didn't coach matt that
was the issue no no no no no no he didn't help him at all He
didn't help.
He didn't help.
He didn't help him at all.
I didn't get shit for Alyssa.
I did that myself.
He didn't help him at all.
You clearly knew how to counter Alyssa.
I literally didn't get any Alyssa coaching.
I'm not anything.
I went into replay.
I was like, oh, this is punishable?
Good to know.
And then I closed it.
He purposely did that, Matt, so he could look good in
comparison to you.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
They swapped.
Oh.
They're not doing Alyssa anymore.
one fight whoa
i was not expecting this we were all training for alissa
okay let's like if we don't press after that you got two
floors
it's back fight
Nice.
Oh.
Shake him to the wall!
Oh god.
Oh.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Push your back.
This is it.
I love that kick.
That's funny.
That's funny that he has that.
Yeah, like a specific back turn for me.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That was her throw break.
She tried the throw break, but it whiffed.
Let's get it.
I'm gonna see it soon, guys.
Oh, I saw it.
That's it.
Oh, that was... Do you step that?
You can't.
It got nerfed, but my punish didn't go through.
Oh, they made it so the second hit doesn't track anymore.
Oh my god, what?
You scared of the graph?
Knee loops.
Nice.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god, it doesn't stop.
Oh, it stopped.
I'm feeling justice here.
Hey, hey.
I'm feeling justice.
I sense it in my bones.
Yep.
Nice.
sir oh my god confident that was i think dude that's
actually a big win because it's us and them between for top
two and now we're even yeah yeah yeah is that real is that
true yeah tony's number one uh as far as i know let me see
oh no i got them mixed up with uh myk sorry we gotta fight
myk nice yeah that's still big that's still big that's still
big i haven't got myk and kfm you just need to do well at
myk then we're good to go oh man he beat me last time
honestly i think this was sabotage for matman if this was
tournament you just lost what does that mean i thought i
thought they lost what's she saying i don't know no it was
three two that was a coach tiebreaker wasn't it yeah for the
yeah yeah no we would have it was a coach tiebreaker i don't
know what they're about but okay no because i won second
round yeah so we yeah that wouldn't happen i don't know
whatever yay man dude whoo all right good i don't think
elisa players can do math that's what i'm saying one more uh
one more round fellas wait they won two three two oh no yeah
because like slime me and matt it's two three it's two three
we're not used to matt losing this is sabotage if only bra
pro top matt how to fade against elisa only matchup i
literally don't know the matchup damn the teams are pretty
even wow the king so one of my chat was like the king
players don't know how do math it's so true it's true
they're hating i mean that's not what their specialty is
yeah we are we're here to grab teens all right
one more set fellas one more set yes sir
no i'm gonna watch myself lose them yk from yesterday Let me
see what I can do.
Yeah, learn from it.
I believe you, new coach.
Did you
be accurate?
It's okay, guys.
This is just round robin, guys.
It doesn't matter.
The finals is when it matters.
The finals is when we're gonna fucking kill everybody.
It's not our fault everybody trained against us.
Like that's so fucked up.
Why did everybody hard train against me?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm fucking brute forcing my way into this tournament
Yay True Why are you trading against me?
It might have been your time Yeah, but it's working.
Yeah.
But, like, but like, it's not our fault.
I can't believe.
I can't believe people train against us.
That's actually so fucked up.
I don't know what I'm doing.
The fact that he trained against the king player.
It, like, perfectly countered me because he knew.
He knew I only had very limited set of moves.
Wait until you...
Master, another move.
I can't believe they Vaughn reviewed.
I didn't Vaughn review.
I just learned new moves.
It's time to learn a seventh move.
You're right.
I just have to learn a seventh move, chat.
That's all I need to do.
Oh, shit.
I just need to learn.
No.
No, I pressed the wrong button.
That's okay.
It doesn't matter.
Because I'm...
Oh, okay.
Because I'm gonna grab her.
Yay.
Three kings in the leading team.
It's just messed up.
It's so messed up.
Okay, I hate playing against this girl.
Because this girl is anti-grab.
It's actually crazy.
Okay.
Like, I can't do the Tomahawk kick with her.
See?
But I can abuse this.
Yay!
Just alley kick.
I know, that's what I did.
Oh, shit.
I didn't expect her to do that.
I didn't expect you to do that.
Oh, my God, you low kick this?
How do I get out?
She got most of her HP back.
They always fall for the allocate because it's so stupid.
It's so fucking stupid.
I'd fall for it because of how dumb it is.
Like, it's just so dumb.
Nobody expects it.
Works every time.
This is why I won and done, because they realize I only know
a specific set of moves.
Get ready for the next battle.
But because it's so low to...
Yeah, it's the worst low.
It's the worst lows.
Nobody preps.
Nobody expects it.
That's so true.
Nobody expects...
Get ready for the next battle.
all right here we go come on oh my gosh she has a gun i'm
gonna kill her she has a gun oh no oh no fucking free
chiropractor yay oh shit no not yeah not yeah anymore guys
not yeah anymore guys not yeah anymore guys it's not stand
up yo slide does she sidestep this no what's up is it ready
no what's up what's up uh dude this is a pretty stressful
man so it's not going to be easy to do this stuff you just
learned yesterday the next day so i wouldn't want to worry
about it too much yeah the gym man it's just like yeah it's
definitely he's an annoying character yeah 100 i think that
i was my gosh he countered that i was just really trying to
focus on defense which is like oh my god when you're
defending goodbye really bad if you're wrong when you're
attacking i feel like it's it's way more at this level yeah
you would you would duck and he would launch goodbye to me i
guess three that axe kick he has yeah and he was also doing
it like kind of raw like i would go for a grab and he just
rip it and i'm like okay well if like it just works block a
little more because because they don't expect it.
So I don't know.
I don't know how much of it was like, this guy's goaded or
this guy's like getting killed.
He's all right.
I played him a little bit.
I think he was taking some rounds off of Matt yesterday, was
it?
I think he said that about the Fang Way, who also destroyed
me.
So I just got to...
Honestly, I don't think they should even...
There should even be in this tier of the Fang specifically.
But, uh...
This is cool.
I mean, we can watch them like tonight or tomorrow.
If you want some matches, if it helps you.
I think what will help is actually playing, like, play your
Jin or your opponent or something.
I can definitely play Jin to that level.
I told you!
It's fine.
Yep, that's what will help.
We can do that, too.
I think that's a good benefit.
If I lose this, it's fine.
I made a statement.
She hates me.
I might have, like, if I lose this, I might have lost the
game, but, like, I want the mental warfare.
The way you said that.
It sounds like it's actually happening.
The way you said it, the tone of the voice.
I want a mental war.
It's all about exactly.
She's gonna remember this forever.
Like the fucking...
Okay.
You know she's gonna fucking remember this forever.
You know that.
The low king.
That's in dying to a low king.
And I leave.
Get ready for the next battle.
Exactly.
Imagine if that person has been grinding all her life to be
in red rank and here I show up.
I show up and all I do is this.
Wait, not that.
Wait, that's sick.
How do I do that?
That's Maoshi!
That's me!
Two touched him.
I fucking two touched him.
That's so funny.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, I tried to block but it didn't work.
Jesus Christ.
Does he duck?
Okay, he doesn't duck.
Okay, that's all that matter.
I just need to know if he ducks or not.
You're cooking this bush in a little bit.
Oh, no.
Fucking two-touching the first game.
Oh, he blocks this.
There's no way he does it.
He's not that stupid.
He's in... He's not that stupid.
Oh, the charge was crazy.
Fight.
Oh, my God.
he tried to sidestep that but he fucked it up and he fucked
that up I feel bad for Fee not having his character brother
a lot of these characters play differently than they used to
in 7 anyways and Fee is literally using fucking the evo
champ character he'll be fine he'll be alright is he done
now?
nope?
those are best at 3 like anything can happen yeah oh
everybody my not yeah it just works like you walked away
from him yeah and bears he needed fucking weird get up oh
wait what that doesn't hit no you more yes no more yes leave
me low i'm sorry
no more yays
steve's counter hit back one of his is main oh this guy
would die the back one plus two hbs one plus two oh shit if
you can find an oh shit please please let me live please let
me live oh my god please i blocked it oh thank god he
doesn't duck what you said not duck you haven't done that
guard break set up today no i haven't no it's okay this is
why we leave too he ducked i can't believe it he actually
ducked he doesn't duck until he does all right guys guys
this time we're gonna use this move one day we'll be able to
use this one we're gonna be able to use this one no okay
this one no okay i'm not be able to do that soon game is
over brother the controller all right wait i'm in a game oh
not being nice because he's winning now okay he's being nice
to you no they'll never see it coming to the toos oh it's
just a motion match wait what rank is he i see through his
lies
Um, okay.
Oh my god, he actually does.
Okay.
Oh, it's Doki.
Maybe she's there.
No, I'm in our game.
No!
I'm sorry!
Don't worry, I'll lose fast!
I'm gonna let him have his Elo.
Oh my god, this guy actually...
Oh my god.
I'm in a game!
Don't worry, I'm gonna lose fast.
It'll be done soon.
Because that guy's beating the shit out of me right now.
Oh, Josh skipped GOMO?
Oh yeah, he's for this.
No, no, no, he's just gonna skip a lot while you're...
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh!
Fight!
What was this motion?
Is that who Matt has to play?
who do you who's who's that gin player oh is that a to oh
there's a bush and gin player in the lobby they got leaked
again no i think it's the to oh oh that's steve oh that's
tasty steve oh i thought he played king that's fine he shows
you how good jinn is i lost on purpose so i can get in i say
that also don't worry my my chat knows it's right it's true
it's true chat i lost on purpose
throwing for content we're starting yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no we're actually in the game getting ready for the match
We're in in I'm late for my my daughter's piano recital He
doesn't care I'm gonna make it now I'm gonna lose for real I
lost because they weren't all there Keep looking to the
stands.
Don't see slime He didn't come damn it how I threw the gate
because I was so sad not because I i'm bad all right cook
our friend gummy here okay don't say that because now look
she sidestepped me
oh my god bro what the hook i saw you when you're getting
hit like that you yeah oh is that that's not a pun no when
you get hit like that just hold back just hold wait is that
i can't tell it's lower sword slasher for mids oh okay
couldn't tell sometimes nice okay good start oh whoa she
ducks it's like she knows oh big good how does she know oh
no i know that's okay doggy now instead of the how long you
just run and knee her if you get distance run and knee her
okay that's the x that's the three right yeah okay okay um
there you go oh my oh my oh my let's go good shit okay that
was crazy let's start fight yeah oh oh my god yeah I fucking
knew you're in I fucking knew it yup okay but what do I do
that oh my god let's go the
flash bait back to the ground you go stop flying who are you
jumping at Yeah!
You don't have wings!
Oh no.
It does have wings.
The Supreme Yoshi Mitsu.
That's counter hit.
You hop kick.
It's fine.
That is so many clicks.
That is so many clicks in my life.
Oh my god.
You might have had 20 hundred coaches, Gumi, but I We just
need one.
That's a lot of kicks, bro.
Round one.
Damn, is that that I musician coaching?
Oh.
Damn, that's a little toxic.
Okay.
You guys called me broke yesterday.
Yeah, we hear the coach.
Nice.
Yep.
Yes, yes.
Oh shit.
What is she doing to me?
Oh she blocked this.
Oh damn.
Yes.
She blocked it.
If she ever jumped, she's going low.
Oh my god.
How did I miss that?
It was just a little late.
Oh I see.
That was crazy.
Oh fuck.
That's my bed.
I didn't know he had it in security.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, that's counter hit.
That's counter hit.
Yeah!
No fucking way, bro.
Okay.
What a break.
Sick break.
Yeah!
Oh shit, I fucked up.
I fucked that up.
Wait, what did she do to me?
I got one plus two grab.
What is that?
Oh, come on.
What the fuck?
How did I miss that?
That was crazy.
Doesn't matter though!
Doesn't matter!
It was a setup.
It was American reset.
One more!
Yes!
You're so fucking good.
You're so good.
Oh shit.
She did that thing.
Hold back.
Wait, I hold back though.
How did...
But I hold back.
How did she do that?
Oh my goodness.
Look for scaling.
Yes.
Did I back up?
No, why?
I got back!
Oh, this is a slow-ass move.
My legs were up.
It wasn't fair.
Oh, oh, shit.
Ra- uh, Raidart, Raidart.
Raidart!
No, I quit it!
I quit it!
She did that thing!
Wait, this is...
No, I quit it, Raidart!
It's okay, it's okay, you got it.
We got it, we got it.
Run your shit, easy.
Boom!
Oh, the mix!
Oh, no, she does that thingy, and it scares me sometimes.
Oh Oh, what the fuck Did I get that that's clean that's good
now I'm scared that she might do hers though when she wakes
up I don't know I don't know if she get in time it's up to
you to commit or don't commit okay We're committing oh shit.
No, what?
How did it not grab?
She was ducking she ducked it.
She ducked it.
So we had the running three.
Yeah, so we had the running knee, the three, the X.
Yeah.
Yeah, ain't no big deal.
Oh, my God.
She actually ducked it.
Who would have thought?
Well, we adapt.
Oh.
How do we adapt?
Wait, what?
Oh, she blew.
Okay.
Nice leg drop.
Shoulder charge?
Yes, sir.
Don't duck.
Yay!
Okay.
Oh, she did that though.
I'm scared of that.
Yay!
Nice!
That's one.
Oh my god, when she does that, it's actually so hard to
count here.
Sure.
Don't duck.
Yay!
Oh.
Nice hop.
Okay.
Oh, I think I blocked it.
Wait, what?
No, you were mashing back three.
Oh, it registered it.
Yeah.
Yeah, my buffered.
Oh, it buffered it.
No!
I mean, you have Raydard too.
What?
Oh, I have to stand up after that.
Down, down, down, back.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
That's gonna burn.
Okay.
Oh, every time she does that.
Yeah, you have to mash four.
If you block it, you, the right kick, the circle to punish
that.
If you block low, mash circle, you'll roll through.
Yeah.
Nice hop.
Oh, I keep my hands is like, Yeah.
Sometimes my hands are in the wrong position.
Got that one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
Final.
You got it.
Let's go Doki.
Okay.
Oh, I hate that attack.
Oh, no, I think she got me from this.
Yeah.
That was close.
Very close.
very close very close it's just that spinning low that's
spinning one always throws me off yeah yeah and we'll work
on that it's very easy so for the turny if we have to fight
her we should be okay it's okay we got the intel now oh wait
do i have to try to press four after i block it or yeah so
while she's spinning if you just mash for that extra kick
that comes out won't come out and you actually hit her.
And there's nothing that she can do to it.
Like, that is like, you get free damage from blocking.
Oh, I see.
Oh, you and J Chen.
Yeah.
We're back.
Should be a fun one.
Flame ruler, damn.
Gotta hit X, bro.
Come on.
I got this.
Bring it back.
I just need to add more moves.
bro let's play the game what the heck what is bro doing rage
art button rage art button slime slime slime it's even here
oh oh shit king ego match oh my god the king mirror this is
it the king mirror
get ready for the next battle
Let's cook.
Round one.
Fight.
Nice.
Got me ducking you.
Oh, different.
Oh my god.
This is this fighting game player, Jason.
This guy fucking playing his fighting games.
Nice duck.
Nice.
Yeah.
What?
dunk cone yes yes bitch yes that's a one or two break went
after the knockdown Kony you have to guess nice nice he
engaged Wow gamer over here rush in after
Nice Yeah, he knows us Okay
Fight Oh, that's gonna die Oh my god I'm trying to duck him
Nice Nice break If you block back one too You can back one
to him back He did it to you earlier It's a punish
Back one Nice Got it Yeah nice nice job let's go yeah let's
fucking go go go go go
fuck i ducked it but i stood up into it yeah it was counter
hit
oh my god that didn't grab yeah it's it he's in he's in full
crouch during uh ain't no thing wow and coney you had your
problem you died with You're right, you're right.
Yeah.
He also didn't use his SSO.
Fuck.
Dude, again, I'm ducking it, but it's like delayed.
Oh.
Did I even grab?
I could have just, no.
Round two.
Fight.
Oh.
nice break nice kick
good duck you're
in hate tony yeah i know okay no big lee maybe let's not
back one two as much in neutral but i mean do what you're
right right fight nice Does he not dunk that?
Nope.
He's a no.
Oh!
Nice!
I'm gonna learn more knee later.
Oh my god.
James.
Fuck.
Yeah.
What a fucking break, Kony.
fuck let's go king nice oh my god cook this man you got this
what a yes oh my god nice
i'm supposed to be a fucking it's supposed to be a fucking
grab
yo there's no You're a fucking legend for blocking that low.
You're a fucking legend for blocking that low.
I got this guy has seven.
I have seven.
He's been dominating slam, but you fucking took him off.
I cannot believe you right now.
Oh my god, you broke his streak.
It was so beautifully clutch.
Let's go.
I can't believe you, bro.
I could feel the layers from here, man.
Round one.
Holy.
This sweat.
This is battles.
It's like rock paper.
scissors.
Okay.
I didn't know that like bounced on wall.
No problem.
There's one.
Round two.
Oh, nice.
Oh, nice!
Oh!
Oh, what a break!
Break!
Nice!
You know what else?
What?
Oh, that's what it is!
You're so clutch.
Yours is just better.
I can't watch this, man.
This is too intense.
Yeah.
Yes!
Oh, good kick.
Huge.
I can't get him!
Mmm.
Oh!
He don't know.
Yeah!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go, Coney.
Yes, bitch!
Fight!
Oh!
The mince!
Oh my god!
The mincece!
I love this man!
I love this!
You said you're gonna buy Bro Pro a drink?
I'm gonna buy you a drink!
Hello?
broke his fucking wind streak yo let's go you killed his
wind streak and took the game break his mind you mind broke
this man that's the evil commentator he's seen it all yeah
you you're actually him just mixes bro just mixes all right
i'm happy that was rough though man he would he's learned
some tricks dude dude the disparity from two days ago i'm
too antsy with the back one too like i i gotta really
fucking stop that but yeah yeah it's pretty bad but yeah
yeah it's really but he's got really bad uh get up habits
like i know where he when he's gonna stand or duck and it
got more obvious over time so sure sure that was scary okay
good well played
most intense matchups yet here we go let's go slime all
right got this what did you own him with last time that he
probably worked on wasn't he free to like back one or i just
got a lot of ones oh you mean him sorry he ate a lot of
electrics okay well try it until it doesn't work because we
don't know what he's labbed and also you know how we labbed
a lot we don't know how much he's retained either you know
what i mean so you can kind of play your game and we can go
from there yep
okay this guy wow what a start genius club one fight oh nice
day
all right that's all right oh
you had that oh here
we go chit oh one down five more yeah
That's what I'm talking about.
That's some go-to right there.
Good blocks, dude.
Downstairs!
Off wall!
Killers.
Had the combo ready and everything.
Nice conversion.
Beautiful conversion.
He's learning!
Wow, that was sick.
Went by the light.
It's cool.
Let her get one string.
You can hear it feel good, you know?
okay do you just want pistons
oh perfect hopkick too oh he wasn't ready he wasn't
what are his longer eat her eat her why is she walking
around
feast mode activated hibernation time i'm going to sleep
let's go slime one more dude three more rounds you got it
round one fight
it's okay he's not gonna learn
nice break
okay oh remember slime stone hit to get out of the wall away
from the wall yeah if your back is on Oh,
that was nice.
Ducks.
That was so sick.
The frame trap with the movement.
Huge.
Keep her on that wall.
Oh my god, that chip.
Jesus Christ.
The infinite pressure.
She did not like that.
Oh, nice flip.
They didn't fucking know, man.
round three fight
good i'm finishing it
good way you knew you knew whipping shit like that you
fucking knew
hold this bro three the go this and that and this and that
and the fish
nice Oh my god, you broke her block!
Oh my god, she's toxic.
That's okay.
That's a counter hit?
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
Like a Wild Rising 1 or something?
Yeah.
It's a frame trap.
Oh, there it was.
Oh, there it is.
Big damage!
Nice, power crush.
It's a good power crush.
It's all right.
I think after while running 1 plus 2 bear stance, he's not
going to duck looking for that grab.
I think you could have done another one, honestly.
Yeah, I think play around the hunting bear stance mixed up.
And when you back 1 hunting bear stance, even though that's
fake as hell, he will eat the bear stance 1 plus 2 every
time.
Okay.
Round one.
Fight.
Yeah, that was good whiff punish.
Nice.
Got all that health back though.
Why does that work?
Okay.
Hot me mashing.
Yeah.
You just have to hold back.
Round two.
Fight.
Okay.
Just laugh.
Oh, she whiffed.
Stone had this man at the wall.
I don't have counter hit, whatever.
Yeah, it was too late, I guess.
Oh, nice!
Look at this!
Round three.
Fight!
Oh.
Look, he doesn't even know it's launched, that's great.
What a cheese.
i didn't mean to do that that looks like this much though
yeah oh that's so good that's good zone head baby oh don't
get me to the wrong side oh doesn't matter doesn't matter
yeah the haunted bear stance that's it guys oh nice hit oh
good again let's fucking punish
i can't believe you broke that that wasn't Incredible.
Nice.
That's again.
She's like they're alone.
I need to be that.
Unblockable.
You have Raid, uh, nice.
when he puts pressure on you, rage, that's my read.
Yeah.
When he puts pressure on you, rage.
Rage, like, where he going?
RICHARD WHERE, left!
You mean, like, this?
This is what you mean.
Like this?
This is what you want, right there.
You mean like this?
Yeah, take it.
Right there!
Red.
One more guess, right?
You have a heat slime.
keep in mind got him let's go fucking rip that let's fucking
go baby yes that's our bear that's our baby that's our big
baby I fucking I saw it and I had to I had to fucking call
it out good fucking shit dude we're earning it bro we're
earning it back
man you guys are incredible Well done.
End in the map, man.
Oh, Lord.
All these matches have been so close.
They're so fucking intense.
All our matches have been.
It's all in the mainstream, too.
It's the big deal.
Dude, I did that unblockable by accident.
It might have looked like DM.
That's what's set up.
That's what, like, oh, man, he's gonna just keycharge me.
I'm gonna mash and he got that rage up for free.
Yeah.
There's all the setup.
This guy's on a four win streak?
That's okay.
It's okay.
You only lost the one person.
You were on an 11 win streak in slams.
Technically like 18.
Across years.
Hit him on the wall, Jack.
Shiny!
Yes, sir.
Uh-oh.
Shiny!
Nice.
I like it.
Oh, and low cute.
Round two.
What was it, good crab?
Shining.
It's not fair.
He has a gun.
Jack has a gun.
Jack is a gun.
Jack has two.
His whole body is a gun.
Jack is his own gun.
These are all gunshots in his combos.
Why do I keep fucking getting that shit, man?
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, send him to retirement home.
Okay, we have to walk that when we make the read on it.
We have to walk.
Oh, man.
Oh, my expulsion.
Expulsion.
It's infamous.
Oh, my God.
Nice!
Serene.
Dropped combo in the kill.
USA, baby.
Let's get it.
USA.
He doesn't know.
Make that grandpa retire.
He's in the corner.
There's walls on each side.
They're closing in.
Good.
Oh, Scar awake!
You've been in the coma for seven years!
He's dead!
Make it stop!
Holy fucking shit, man!
His heart stopped midway!
Oh, Bro's counting!
I want to say one!
Damn!
um
Yeah, what a counter hit Oh, that was good Oh, let's go not
new time.
Let's go not new time nice round two fight Thank you.
Oh, okay Blood was looking at his shoes.
Oh god He is a gun!
He is a gun!
Guys, I don't even think we have to...
We don't have to wait on Sunday!
He's back now!
Uh-oh!
With the white flag that you're in.
No, not there!
Not there!
No!
Not here!
I can't believe that.
explosion earlier what no way what the fuck is that damage
that was a good break by the explosion damage oh good break
though nice oh
my god oh my god oh my god is that a good Call the
ambulance.
Call the ambulance.
It's over.
In three games, Jack Jesus came back.
That's an infinite tech trap.
You have to get up correctly, otherwise you literally die.
It's a miracle.
That's crazy.
This is what it is.
It's a miracle.
Oh, bear time.
All right, coach.
Get him, coach.
Hey, I mean, that's three wins against them, right?
There's a bad character.
Yeah, but you gotta get my revenge.
he's good man you gotta redeem me I'm just gonna play my
best whatever happens happens your best bro that's even you
got it I just just do your best I'm
gonna close my chat there it is okay oh my god he's a polar
bear global warming is real this yeah they're on a boat yeah
yeah shit's bad The iceberg's melted and he's in Paris!
Show him you're the better mammal.
Good patience.
Good duck.
Damn.
Aw.
Back then, no problem.
Good shit.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my shiny wizard isn't coming out.
if they can hit it thanks okay is it wall let's go right in
there yeah he's lucky that's retracted make them extinct oh
no way it whiffed what the hell just the way he stands with
his legs back i guess i mean i would if i could be if i got
punched in the nuts
holy okay oh my god throw them off the boat ring out no it's
not that fake oh that fake oh
nice oh nice well done oh yeah that's guaranteed yeah that
was a guess for game situation oh it's cool it's fine it's
fine coach a little bit
that was bear Yeah, Slav is taking notes right now.
You might as well prolong this match so you can take more
notes.
What's though?
Oh, he broke that.
He missed his health sweep.
His dusty ass health sweep, we missed it.
Nice!
Oh, no way.
Ask for life!
Ask for your fucking life!
That's our coach!
One more, one more, one more!
gots the ass hell sweep i love you bro bro let's go i can't
believe he didn't duck there you can do it round one it's
the mental games show him you're the apex predator
oh no way it crushes mids
the alley kick we love it
nice break that off
There it is boys.
There's the counter play.
Nice job.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god, that was a bad situation to be in.
I got nothing but Kuma cake on my screen.
Yummy.
In 4k just big bear ass.
For free?
Oh no, fuck.
Nice.
Okay, we gave them one.
Let's go.
Round three.
fight
This fucking rock of your scissors Ooh backs
up okay We're getting back up about it.
You're not biting the fucking bay either.
Are you unc?
This is this is such a coach Oh
Oh nice kick Bow what the i'm talking about one more dude
one more bro it's a turn-based game it is
nice kick oh wow oh yeah any problem mix happens mix happens
huge oh nice oh my nice Nice.
Nice.
Yeah.
I was choosing not to go behind their stance.
Let's fucking go.
One hit.
Oh.
Watch him block him.
Yes!
That's crazy to me.
That's just smart fucking hit smash.
Oh my god, the bait.
That's gone.
Oh!
That's a crazy G club.
You were in the air though, right?
It's not gonna be alive.
Yeah, I mean, it's still gonna take all my great life.
Gaming.
Yes!
Let's go!
That's what I'm fucking fucking about!
I just barely eat.
What the fuck are you doing?
This will drop me!
Oh my god!
Coach Reed!
Coach, what are you doing?
Good shit.
If I do that, you'll be mad at me!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, man.
Yeah, do as I say, not as I did.
This will drop me.
Hey, I didn't want to put the pressure on you.
I think we're second seed because you won that.
Because we won.
Wait, did we are we like a seed?
Because of that?
I didn't want to say shit.
Like that was the tiebreaker.
Really?
You got it.
You got some tiebreaker, dude.
Oh my god.
That is why we tell you after you won.
I didn't want to say it.
But their first seed and we're second.
Yeah, we literally just like last time we got a seed.
We got a one.
I would have lost if you guys told me, man.
No, I was silent.
That's why I said it.
I didn't say it.
You closed the chat, bro.
Close the chat.
Cody and I had like a neural link.
We just knew that it would just not be good to say.
say that shit holy fuck nice fucking oh my god we literally
all performed yay that was yeah dude shit guys we i'm so
happy i'm so happy we earned it we earned the second oh my
god we did we came back at the end yes that's great we don't
have to do anything for the first match let's go fucking
shit guys we get the chill we get the scout bye yep we get
the watch thank god i love guys man so that was fucking sick
well done it was incredible everybody came together it was
all the sets were so close to fuck yeah clutched it bro so
and they all trained against us they actually studied us
that's true actually yeah they did a lot oh my yeah they
actually did their homework dude did you know last last time
the tiebreaker was against nyk also really yeah for the evo
was against you're just better bro you're just better all
right we uh yeah i think we're second seed nice wow we got a
lot of work to do we got a lot of work to do oh yes and this
time bravo will teach matt oh wait we're third seed oh never
mind we're third oh what what after four that's crazy after
4-1.
That's okay.
We'll cook them.
I'm not worried about second and third.
We play another set, but like, you know.
Don't worry about it.
Don't just imagine we're second.
Okay, never let the king players do math.
Ride the high.
That's true.
Told me it was second.
My bad, yo.
I can't believe it.
Believing the chat?
The chat got me killed the other day.
You're right.
My bad, bro.
Can't listen to him.
You're right.
Second in our heart.
Unless it comes down to like a weird...
What?
Yeah, what are the points looking like?
I want to look at them.
Wait, no, yeah, because we're 14-1.
We were tied with KFM.
They're crunching the numbers.
Oh, wait, Tony.
Yeah, they're crunching the numbers.
Okay, we'll see.
Now SageM confirmed for a second?
I don't like this.
Wait, now they could be gaslighting.
Oh, we're tied for a second.
They're saying Tekken Ball.
Tekken Ball, Tekken Ball.
Let me play Tekken Ball.
It will dominate.
say jam messed up what i read chat stop stop stop hold on
i'm banning you actually okay let's look never believe chat
except if it's check and ball let me play spreadsheet wait
yeah wait if we had more if we had if us and myk had the
same amount of points today but we had one more point
wednesday right oh yeah yeah i mean it's it's additive so i
don't all right they're crunching they're crunching we're
tied for second if it's tech and ball put me on they're
saying we're tied for second but they didn't include
yesterday so we're second including yesterday's points
apparently that's what say jam said if me and my care tied
we should get it because i just beat the coach yeah the
match is just not real real i should get it because it was
fucking stressful wait second by three points oh we're
second by three points Let's go!
We're gonna do about three points?
Let's fucking- Yeah!
So, doesn't that mean literally if one of us lost yesterday,
then we would have taken balled?
Yes.
Oh, my God.
You guys clutched it out yesterday, or two days ago.
Dude!
Oh, my God.
Yesterday.
Yesterday was all that matters, because we got first last
one.
It literally fucking matters.
NYK's in third now.
Yay!
Wait, who do we play against then?
I was just a rollercoaster.
I was so ready to take and ball it up, dude.
I got strategies that I don't even want to talk.
about i don't want to tell you guys just how much it grinded
that Wednesday actually mattered three point diff that's
literally a one game difference that literally literally
means everyone who won like good needed every single
everyone matters good fucking let's go this is so sick
because like everyone on the team like it contributes not
everybody's coming oh i can hear josh so so when is someone
gonna name drop super a lot bigger streak than that already
one more in case than super i love the guy but i i feel like
the donkey bird special the alley kick special oh yeah my as
soon as we learn to block that yoshi the spin of rudy
bullshit it's yeah yeah yeah the moment i block that it's
over i can alley kick forever do you think they're gonna
learn how to block the alley kick guys we were only two
points away from first also oh yeah if we won one more set
against it but i mean first or second doesn't yeah it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter right we're just on the
other side of the bracket from my understanding okay don't
this doesn't matter if i'm like hey our third seed then we
just forewond them so like yeah we're not in a bad spot good
i'm gonna ask i'm gonna ask stage one see if anyone wants to
play the second one and also uh we don't have once the
bracket comes out we don't have to focus on like five
characters because we we get a buy yeah well maybe we might
with the loser bracket i don't know actually how that works
let's not to prepare yeah for whatever comes up yeah i think
it's mathematically we'll be less characters to focus on the
moment you teach me how to block i'm unstoppable yeah no
yeah we'll do all that Like, it'll be a read, but by
definition, we have to lab against, like, at least one less
team.
Oh, good shit, guys.
Well done today.
Seriously.
Hell yeah.
Wow.
Crazy.
This is really, like, rough on the mental.
I'm not going to lie.
Dude, my brain run ironically hurts.
And the thing, like, I don't...
I don't know.
It's just pride, because, like, we're already going.
You don't need to be here alone, bro.
I'm here, too.
you just don't want to let your friends down it's so hard
luckily like i don't want to let you guys down you know i
mean but like at the same time doesn't matter yeah we're
already going wait hello guys hello
we can we can create a like a little a little thing a group
thing we'll just all pick them because you're part of the
team true yeah let's do it for dokey though that's the first
option then then then we we'll do a donation drive for a
millionaire after yeah first option is we try and get top
two i'm not gonna use my own money one by two points oh i
would have loved beat josh's team so bad if you beat josh
bro would have been first seed oh my god i lost to his coach
no it is just time it's okay i choked too guys it's okay we
all each of us choked at least once guys it's okay it's a
team That is a second though as a team at first.
Yeah, yeah.
But Chad is saying give her super's ticket.
That's what my Chad's saying.
That's what I'm saying, dude.
Drop it over.
Make super pay for his own ticket.
I gave away my first ticket because I already had an Evo
fucking, like I already had a ticket.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yeah, I was like, here, SageM, just give it to someone else.
SageM saves money if we win.
Yeah.
So it's in his interest to rig the bracket.
Oh, that's true.
Oh, look at how close we were, dude.
Oh, my God.
We're so close.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
If by, you know, knock on wood, not going to happen.
But if we don't get top two, we'll all pitch in, get Doki to
Evo too.
Yeah.
Because I mean, clutch master Doki, literally every match
mattered.
Doki clutched that shit.
Yeah.
Wait, because my set counted?
Oh, well, every single set, every win counted.
Every win.
That's literally the reason you got it.
There's no way I don't, like, you deserve to be at EVO.
Yeah.
I got points from SK.
Yeah, you fucking, you literally farmed.
Well, every step mattered.
I don't think every match, right?
How did it work?
Every match turns into every set and every set matters.
Okay.
So you got points off the guys you beat.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, off the points, like, I got sets off.
Yeah.
so how many people did you beat in a set it was like a
couple right i beat a more but then i got set off sk and
gloomy you went like uh what like two three three two yeah
two three yeah so like literally that's that's actually a
difference maker like it's crazy whoa that rate that that
king he eats when he's growling yay that's a good put that
was a really it was like right as he looked into the camera
that's very funny okay did you see it did you see the clip
no chat send it send me the clip please it's extremely funny
my my pov yeah hold on here you go i'm gonna post it in the
thing yeah i want to see it is extremely good hold on uh
here you go watch this put this on stream yay title title
all right okay I'm gonna go get food congratulations
everyone we're the goats are you just raining yeah uncle are
you staying live me uh I mean what am I gonna do I guess
I'll stay live for like 30 minutes or something sure all
right we'll give brawl bro I'll say brawl so enthusiastic
okay okay let me give my 90 second ad ready hold on oh yeah
yeah get the ad revenue i'm ready i'm ready all right good
bro all right guys see you in two days later ggs guys yeah
we'll train we'll train bro let's get yeah we're gonna train
for real let's fucking get you guys see me in purple rank
tgs oh my god guys we got second sk in gloomy it's an
improvement I gotta say almost everybody.
Oh my god, Brawl Paul's fucking jamming it out right now.
Guys, it's okay.
In the finals, we're definitely gonna have our new PC.
And the shackles will be off.
For real.
And we got Red Rank on stream too.
Guys, we got Red Rank on stream.
To be fair, I feel like I've been...
honestly feel like I brute force the red rank because all I
did was just do the moves I know and then leave I just I
just do like the most tilting fucking moves that nobody has
ever seen before I call it the dokey special with five alley
kicks and then into a hop kick red red is red these people
in those rinks did not know what they saw.
I'm pretty sure I tilted a lot of people.
I was so surprised that the match against SK was so close
because she had so many hours ahead of me.
I like hard-grinded the last this week, but like SK still
had so many hours ahead of me.
Like everybody had so many hours ahead of me throughout this
tournament.
So I felt like I definitely grew a lot.
in such a short amount of time and uh and i did i don't like
i don't death in i just go in yolo the mind game i feel like
i caught up really fast in the short amount of hours i think
i have like 30 hours in total at the moment in techin for
now but i'm pretty like i um and it's my first fighting game
so i'm really happy with my progress so far like i never
expected to get red So I'm super happy with my progress And
I honestly think the moment I learn how to block it's
fucking over for everybody That's my only problem The moment
I learn to block and I become more patient It's over I
figured it out Because I win the mental game Like I win the
mind games off of people Because when they fight against me
it's so i can feel the rage i can feel people being really
angry when they're fighting against me because my moods are
so fucking bullshit like my moods are so are so bullshit
that i can tell people are very mad you see them get more
aggressive oh hell yeah yeah i can feel that they're
deafening and like going hard focused i can feel it i just
need to like i just need to learn how to block and it's over
the block alley kick alley kick jump kick bam done they
better learn hey guys i hope you guys enjoyed today's uh
event we got second place overall it was so close too we're
second place overall that's real i'm really proud of my team
and i'm happy that uh my sets actually contributed to i
because i thought like since I only won one game that that
was it I only contributed one game but like I'm happy that
my sets actually mattered and it actually contributed into
the score overall so like I'm glad that I'm happy that it
actually helped the team with the score so yay because I
didn't lose both sets I like one like one out of like a set
which is why why I'm happy hey guys I'm gonna call it here
I'm gonna like relax a little bit get some back behind the
done um and then i'll start training again tomorrow as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing any of you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye